for what will be an exciting matchup
ahead Danya always a pleasure to be with
you and let me ask your opinion on this
match we were just behind the scenes
talking the players make sure everything
was settled this is bound to be a great
match but who do you have taking this
one between these two fighters Robert
you know how much I love that question
you know how good I am at answering it
and I think that in my experience
watching these matches I feel like
specific experience Blanc blitz and
bullet on line is probably the biggest
x-factor so I'm gonna have to go with
Eric here as the very very slight
favorite but that being said I was very
impressed of the way Alena played in her
first-round matchup against Chris Stubbs
alecky who is you know is an incredibly
strong player in his own right so I
think this is gonna be a very close
match seat belts fastened and mandatory
Robert
well Eric did beat Le pates 17 to 7 in
that opening round matchup it was quite
a decisive victory in his favor I think
she tilted she said as much in the post
match interview and for a Lina cash and
sky she won 13 to 11 over chess
explained that was one of our epic
first-round battles of course we also
saw Danny wrench and Teddy Coleman go to
extra time and in that ended in Teddy's
favor so we remember fondly that opening
round matchup with only no costume sky
she's clearly informed when it comes to
some of these time scrambles but you're
right Erika's far more experienced he
has a very loyal devoted following and
I'm sure we'll see those people in the
chat today absolutely we will and we
should also mention that Eric has
incredibly strong opening preparation
I've always been impressed with it he
sometimes plays openings that appear to
be very not to us like he's of course a
champion of the London system many
people know that but all of his openings
have a lot of bite to them and he takes
that very very seriously so I think that
preparation is going to come in handy
today of course alena winning the first
match and now she's able to make some
adjustments so I'm sure she approached
the games room a first round match very
seriously she's made the necessary
conclusions and it's you know almost
like she's married to a certain decent
player who may
may not have helped her with some
opening preparation as well so I'm very
excited to actually see what the
openings in this match look like and who
wins that particular sub battle yeah it
is interesting as you said because Eric
Rosen
he sort of lays these offbeat London
type positions but he knows him
extremely well he knows all of the
tricks and traps involved in that
opening we're gonna catch the sky a very
principled player she is married to a
bratislava boy Tasha coolest an elite
Grandmaster a super Grandmaster but she
herself has shown that she has exquisite
opening preparation I mentioned during
her previous match that in the Isle of
Man 2018 she drew a nice giri she drew
Vladimir Kramnik she beat Sam 7 doing
you say any more of her results she's on
the cusp of becoming a grandmaster
so by VA rating she is the highest rated
player in the field some the other
players maybe have had a higher peak
rating since we saw Una's at on sneak
peek 225 37 3 day but Alina Cashman
skaia when she's flying over the board
these days she's an absolute force to be
reckoned with
absolutely I mean she she's capable of
beating anyone when she's on fire is
absolutely a force to be reckoned with
so very very excited to see how this
match unfolds and we have liftoff right
now so you don't have to be excited to
see you get to see right now and we see
a luna costume sky with the white pieces
she plays her very typical she starts
with a Queen's pawn and now we would
trade on d5 so what do you think about
you know we'll see how the next few
moves go Danya but Eric already and just
a very calm setup here from the black
side yeah we have a Carlsbad structure
which you know has been around for over
a hundred years this has been so well
studied White's immediately clear
planets to basically play F 3 and E 4 to
prepare the central thrust Black has
played on the Queen side black is also
just incredibly solid overall we see the
Mexican a moves very very quickly
Eric trying to get his knight to be for
Elena stopping that very solid position
for both sides really this is gonna be a
maneuvering game but it can get very
very tactical if the center is opened
right and now then that comes to e6 and
white has ideas with F 3 and E 4 where
you just try to say I'm going to expand
you're in center
you start capturing me on e4 you open up
the F file after EFT a c4 and your
knight on f6 is currently pinged to the
Queen on ba correct exactly and so we
see Ali I'm bringing her up to d1 and
it's very important to time the move f3
correctly because if you miss time it or
you play prematurely black can
counter-strike with a move like c5 or
there's a bunch of tactics that no white
center can crumble very very quickly so
a lot of Carlsbad is this cat-and-mouse
game or White's trying to find the right
timing the play of three four blacks
trying to stop her and develop counter
play in his own right
right and we see Knight g5 but this is
the Cossack or Lee he had that
remarkable victory I remember these
Knights on f6 and g5 it allows you to
play Knight F to e4 and at some point
you are going to sacrifice your knight
on d5 that's sort of the intention here
well if this knight on f6 is not in the
way you play a move like Knight takes h3
and then the issue on h4
is done mm-hmm that's a I really like
them of Knight g5 also we're stopping f3
directly because e3 is gonna hang I mean
this is just a sampling Eric all of
these opening ideas as you mentioned
Robert some of them look offbeat but
they always carry carry a bite and Elena
very principles move f4 chasing that
night away so it's black gonna take on
h3 or no he goes 96 but now of course
white is weakened herself as well I
liked your idea with 19 stage 3 check
unfortunately I feel like this is a
position where it's more Hope than
actual potential success if we just
scroll back here in 98 3 GHz Bishop h3
you're hitting my rook on f4 and you're
hitting my pawn on e3 but I can play
rook f3 and at once defend both of those
problems yeah that's a good point
I was thinking of taking on e3 after G
takes h3 but I agree it's a little bit
speculative ah but now this movie for by
alina what if Eric just takes only four
goes Bishop e7 and claims that oh I have
this d5 square how is this going to
unfold and you're absolutely right this
isolated pawn here on d4 can't push you
point out you're the d5 square whenever
somebody has nicely a pond you want to
plant a pony right in front of it or
another piece but here the knight on f6
to come 55 at the right moment and
also playing very quickly so it's not an
easy position to play but he has made it
look relatively easy with this night
outs g5 and back to e6 and right now we
know offering some trades and can she
punched through d5 that's one of the
essential questions here and she plays
Bishop c4 just for that purpose I want
to play d4 to d5 next open up my rook on
d1 as well as my bishop landing on the
d5 square where the pawn on b7 will be a
potential target and Danya you know it
seems like black is a little bit cramped
a little bit underdeveloped but White
has a potential issue of being
overextended we look at the ER me square
97 would be a try here as well yeah I
like your knight c7 moved you think
you're not getting d5 and so easily and
then I'll play Bishop to e6 when I see
seven drop back trade bishops and cover
that d5 square yeah this pawn on f4 is
is sort of sticking out like a sore
thumb and yes black is kind of cramped
he's gonna watch this diagonal a 2 to g8
there's some tactics on the g6 square
but after 97 if you can get his Bishop
out to let's say a five or six um White
has maybe a dynamic initiative but all
of the static advantages are RM blacks
favor here so this is gonna be really a
question of whether aleena can can make
something happen in the next couple of
modes I think you're maybe ninety seven
ninety three maybe why it's not much
worse positionally but still Eric taking
his time here maybe there's another move
or maybe something is scaring him off
about my stuff I'm not sure maybe
there's f5 for why I was wondering if
that was what was scaring him off I know
that closed down your Bishop a tube it
should be one check amending idea and
now Bishop b1 is very tempting but then
the net will retreat to f8 because once
the knight gets to f8 h seven is under
the Knights control you're not going to
make me I have the open e file I'm happy
as black but I was wondering if that was
the what the issue was that somehow if
we just go back a second nice he's an f5
Richard bishop on c8 going here and you
can still play d5 Bishop d7 but I don't
really like that idea regardless of
women's play and as we return to the
game position here like you look at that
from b7 you desperately need a
move like c5 or b4 bishop a6 or some
moment to make that bishop even look
remotely useful but Danya I don't see
how that's going to happen respect what
about 94 Knight takes d4 that's a pawn
I'm
struggling to figure out what Alena has
in mind against that move I want to play
Knight age five Sacopee so might is if
you take on c2 I taken up safety g-57
but I don't think I'm you know quick
enough to be a shot see and that's
actually interesting yeah where are you
getting this creativity from Robert your
needs memorization to me done yet man
yeah you you're making me emotional you
don't please don't make me
yeah this much but now c5 Noah this is
definitely going this is this is going
haywire for Alina because now Robert you
mentioned that Bishop that Bishop is
activated look at that monster on d4
there was something something something
went wrong here for Alina she
miscalculated something and now I think
this is just lost for white yeah all the
flax piece is perfectly coordinated and
ease upon up it looks terrible if I'm
being completely honest with you because
the run b7 as you point out an
excellent piece and then it before it
protected outpost there and it's not
easy to pick that day you can't get a 90
to move which is what you would need
whites best chances if somehow you can
initiate a series of trades and then get
that night off d4 and play a pond down
that still gives black all the chance in
the world to convert this into a victory
but at least in that case you have some
chances to hold the game and after Queen
about rookie - yep rookie to rock after
- Knight f3 check is very strong I think
you might as well just bust through the
gates I love it when you spy tactics
tactics you just unleashed the Danya
beast that we all know and love there
well my tactics work about one time out
of ten in real games but as we like to
say Herbert sacrificing other people's
peace is easy it is easy and I love
rookie - we both saw it
Oh Quincy six play six the point was the
knight couldn't take on e2 because when
the Black Knight landed on me to open a
fort and right now you know she's still
in this game and look at Eric's clock
he's down to one minute thirty seconds
we saw in his first round match it's le
page that he was the one who was ahead
in the clock and Stubbins had dubious
positions but beheld thanks to good
clock management and defensive tenacity
and resourcefulness so right now I don't
see the clear break do Ferrara in there
he's going to spend some serious time in
this moment but da yo a minute 15 to 2
minutes 15 at Queen mu to play repeats
you there and this is exactly three was
good with the Queen on statistics also
yeah you were
the possibility of trade slowly white
gets wagon again the problem is that
even after the Queen's are off the board
I just don't see how white can hold the
position together right
it's not easy of course not but it's
perhaps manageable and right now there's
these unites discovery attacks or f6 you
can even take that pawn because rook
can't capture on f6 and the reason why
is that rook on d1 needs a defender as
any Knight discovery will pick up this
rook on d1 so if for example maybe to
check the rook we're not already
protecting d1 you win that rooks that's
why f6 you need to capture it rook to g5
of course and there it is
King H - I don't have 92 yet because now
the black knight is pinned to the rook
on d8 so H 5 H 4 is one idea to try to
take advantage of the fact that the
knight on G 3 is pinned to the pawn on
g2 with the bishop staring down along
with the rope yeah this is not easy
g6 but now that pawn in f6 is like a
thorn Ruby e1 and then all of a sudden
White's threatening Bishop takes f7 to
check in Turkey 7 oh I like it
the thing is and for example d1 black
and go c4 to try to shut down the bishop
but then leaning could go a 4 it's all
about kind of with 49 seconds on the
clock you just have to find one move at
a time - to pose small tactical tasks
for black and soon you'll find his time
evaporating so definitely Lina in the
game which she's got to be very precise
here and how she handles this
opportunity I think rip d1 is actually
quite annoying and there we have it and
rip d1 is great as done you said and we
can analyze it very quickly
the threat is Bishop takes f7 check
first not rookie 7 first and c4 stopped
it just to show everybody if you made
some random like b4 bishop f7 check King
f7 rookie 7 check you pick up this
Bishop on b7 so then we go back to the
live game here and we see that c4 closes
the bishop down rookie 7 still comes
without the same power it doesn't the
same punch as when the bishop were
attacking spawn f7 yeah I I thought a4
was interesting but now I like what
Elena's doing she's trying to get her
Bishop T for the promise Bishop b4 meets
with age 4 now even that is not lost in
that h1 she goes rook up for though I
really like what she's doing here look
at her bringing all these pieces in 96
rook can drop back to f2
yeah
the night has the c4 squared this is
definitely still better for black but
Eric has made a hash of this and he's
down to 20 seconds and easy I mean I
don't want to call myself a prophet or
anything like that but exactly what I
was saying is happening here it's
getting difficult she's pretty up
tenacious defense watch out for a work
takes me six in a tiny moment whirling
f-pawn Springs free not here but just
keep that the back your mind sometimes
you sack that exchange of credit passed
pawn maybe it should be for like you
were saying just to trade some pieces
and hope that you can survive this pawn
down endgame and the rook on e7 is a
very nice piece for white how do we
activate this Bishop I would love to get
my Bishop back on the a2 dot to have 7
square but I can't get it with on c4
well as the Nostradamus among the two of
us maybe you should be the one answering
answering the question fact I mean given
your new status as a prophet I'd like
you to tell me what the first move is
gonna be in the next game I mean there's
so many questions I have for you about
my life and how it's gonna unfold but
yeah this bishop on c2 Bishop takes g6 I
keep looking at that move but you never
quite make it work
maybe a four maybe try to open a second
front
but now Bishop g6 one it gets very sharp
yep but h4 was always hanging so you
knew you were able to take on h4 even in
that position 795 Knight takes h4 move
Bishop g6 and have rook takes the HF it
was maybe yeah perfect
rook to see oh okay but was that winning
though oh my gosh mr. g6 did you know
maybe yeah in the route g7 but we gotta
watch out because rook to d1 comes at
the end and then you should occur
alright this is where I get stressed out
yes before only move to make space for
your King because now you can you could
run away like no in the King run staff
for what should be winning here look at
the King activity all the sudden the
positives 6 is very very strong here
king of five keep forget for his weight
nice move mmm oh yeah
seven up seven yeah I've said all of
seven rip GA was winning this I I was
going for Rick h6 I said that you played
it and now all of a sudden Eric Rosen
should survive this yeah give us up says
draw c300
working changes to report yeah okay now
I can push for a little longer he's got
one second he's stressing me out
yes she can but the thing is such an
easy droid JIT is lacking in front of
the pawn and there's no way Eric is
yeah you can come free move a bunch of
moves here basically yeah yeah I exactly
this is a drop Wow
and there we see a drop by agreement and
what a game that was I'm going to pull
up that last game once more was shouting
analysis board with a live game the
opening stages take shape but we're
gonna pull this up here because we saw
you saw I should say week you're the one
who found it first these great Bishop
takes g6 ideas by Alena she survived
this way and not only was she surviving
she was winning this position because
had she played after HTT p-- on f7
followed up with rook to ga check
forcing through a queen she would have
actually won that first game but that
was a very back and forth battle Eric
clearly the upper hand out of the
opening and now we're in the second game
here and the leanest not just survive
she had a chance to win but ultimately
there was peace on the board well yeah I
think at some point aleena had around 20
seconds and and she kind of got into
time scramble mode maybe a little bit
too early that was when you know the end
game madness was happening and she had
those chances to go for checkmate so
that's an adjustment she could think
about mating this is a very sharp line
of the London system pretty well known
after Queen takes h5 yeah there's a lot
of theory here white basically sacs the
pawn on c4 and goes like h4 h5 as far as
I remember or Knight F yeah and and and
he's just going for checkmate here so
this is an example of how sharp the
London system can get and how venomous
it could be especially if black isn't
up-to-date with recent theoretical
developments yeah and this is just
craziness right you have a g6 being keto
type pawn structure but the black Bishop
is outside of the pawn chain which makes
it a target and that's why h4 comes in
it hits the bishop immediately but soon
it's gonna go to h5 take on g6 and just
crack open what looks like a formidable
defensive setup for black on the Kings
side once I get I open on the H file it
can spell big trouble and look at Ali no
she takes on c3 after some serious
thought here and now that Eric is
thinking and this is one of those
interesting moments down here where you
and I both have played many tournaments
over the board and our opponents coming
in with quick preparation and then all
of a sudden you make a move and they
stop and think it's either because you
made a bad move or because your point
doesn't know the line more deeply than
that moment
so it's I'm here to see how this game
ends up because does Eric know this to
its completion or economy you know how
deep does he really know it I think he
knows it quite deep I mean DC from my
limited analysis I don't really remember
that move but usually in the situation
you mentioned I get terrified that I've
made a huge blunder because they didn't
consider it in their preparation and
that must mean it's a terrible move now
here I definitely am NOT envious of
Elena's position that on g5 and I mean
those are like crab claws just clamping
down on black skin each side it's paving
the way for something like queen up for
it Eric very patiently goes 83 to stop
Queen before I just I think the computer
probably would give something resembling
equality but practically speaking so
much easier to play with the white
pieces here despite the absence of a
pond
yeah because wife's plan is simple rook
h6 move your king bring your rook to h1
win the h7 pond checkmate on h8 and then
other accommodate so did I say that more
or less accurately you basically done
mean that's just like my life plan make
a billion dollars by penthouse in
Manhattan retire I have a great life
easy easy easy easy I don't know why
everyone doesn't do that sounds about
right but you know black could have
thrown in each v type of move but the
problem is white probably wouldn't take
it on pass on as soon as you play age 5
I can't take compass on right I can just
steal that pawn and go for the attack
and well now I see that the Queen h4 she
has to play h5 to stop this checkmate
and that's the perfect moment to do so
right if Queen h4 h5 you take on myself
I get to trade Queens and you don't have
an attack and you're losing a piece and
even if you weren't losing the piece on
d3 pretend that wasn't there just your
tax car we traded Queens and now my king
can hide on each seven yeah why needs to
be very precise er I'm thinking of
something like Bishop takes a6 or okay
six and then there's a couple of ideas
that I can consider trying to implement
one is to basically play either King e2
or King t2 and try to organize some sort
of shock on h7 another is to go rook h6
to prevent this idea of h5 but the
problem there is White's King itself is
a little bit unsafe I mean it's on e1
okay he goes rook so you want to plug
the holes and attack the knight I like
that move a lot and once he's
improves queenside situations then he
can think about basically going to look
age six for example yeah and the rook on
d6 is not a happy square for that piece
because it needs to stay coordinated
with the other Brooke and I like Eric's
move up to c1 because he's attacking on
two fronts
he's saying I'm going to get the C file
and I'm going to check with my you down
the H file and you have to be looking
both ways to figure out wait a second
which one's gonna happen first and b5 is
played that looks like an aggressive
move but spread more out of necessity
and I like it because what Alena needs
desperately needs is some form of
counter play here there might be a four
file by b4 breaking open the queenside
rook h6 played by Erik he's saying okay
here comes Queen h4 and let me go take
on h7 yeah go check meet you and that's
a great plan if you'll uh I mean Elena's
several options King g7 being one of
them intending Queen h4 okay shape
another is you can wait for Queen h4 and
then go f5 off his foot that allows onto
Sun and that's just nastiness but in
terms of staving off me that's both of
those are much better than giving up h7
I think maybe Elena's opting for the
second choice
I still I feel like that's just got to
be losing though II takes f6 on pass on
that Bishop d6 comes in I mean
everything starts to crumble there just
looks like a brilliant attack but if
black is able to what what wait what if
we're good oh we before check oh that's
insane what an idea but decisions work
that is the essential question does it
work is how I feel that all of my ideas
here I've a great idea you're thinking
of there buddy but doesn't work and the
answer typically is no but it wouldn't
matter for check I mean just afraid the
Queen's off the thing about this
position though is blacks King isn't
really safe even with the Queen's off
the board yeah sure that's gonna be
slicing off the the fourth ring so that
Queen before no longer forces a queen
trick but I can feel like black might
have something here
Knight takes e5 and after 95 where's
Mitch 1193 check in f1 Queen B 2 and I
covered the h8 square
I have threatened Queens except to check
to get rid of your queen and get your
broken h7 under attack oh my gosh Stevie
it's Grandmaster you and
they're very interesting I mean you're
basically defending from the other side
that's that's the power of a queen it's
such a long-range piece and you never
cease to marvel it at the Queen's
capabilities of defending from the other
side of the board that's exactly what a
Lina does Wow what I've observed so far
in these first two games she's seizing
her opportunities in very difficult
position positions just incredible
tenacity not to jump to conclusions but
I've been very impressed with the way
that that she's handled these these
situations the theme of the match
certainly has been eric gets a superior
position out of the opening and alina
fights back
with tremendous force and in this case
i'm sorry to like her position because i
don't see a clear winning path for erik
anymore of course if you get one more
movie whatever cage a check but here
came the Queen to be to covering this
square here and threatening the rook on
c1 is she wanted for in fact it's like
it's a free move let's say you move your
rook somewhere Knight takes f4 simply
wins a piece because the queen is
attached the rook is an overloaded piece
this is when you hear that word
overloaded this is the quintessential
example of it if you put that word in
the dictionary and won a chess position
this is a great one because the Queen
needs to protect the rook on h7 it needs
to protect f2 which is a mating square
it needs to protect the fish one at four
and the rook let's say one is under
attack wow this is actually awesome
stuff it is and I was thinking about
Bishop e3 here intending Knight takes
you on by 54 but black is essentially
spoiled for choice here there even Queen
takes d4 in King age sevens a practical
practical way to get a position with you
know only winning chances and I'm sure
there's probably some sort of
combination of checks there that's even
stronger than that but I mean I don't
see what to do Eric's position is
falling all right that's the danger of
throwing all of your trips into the
center of the table if it doesn't work
out your position crumbles immediately
and that's kind of what we see here just
yeah this knight on d3 came in and a
miraculous time Knight takes e5 was a
great resource available to Alina just
because of rook can see one who needed
the bishops defense for that moment and
rook see two rooks I was thinking about
that but I didn't yak when anyone
seconds because Knight takes f4 again
the Queen is overloaded protecting the
rook on H
so I'm going to win your Bishop and now
Knight 681 yeah and then G 3 but then 93
and and black just collects everything
the rook on c2 is toast as well and the
problem why there's no way to generate
any further threats on the King side
amazingly h8 is the only square that's a
potential mating square
it's very safely covered by that Queen
on a1 the Queen on a1 cannot even come
close to being dislodged by any of why
does no pieces left you need this rook
to jump from c2 over to the H file but
it takes so long your king is under
attack on anyone checked I mean you know
all that you saw this happening and
you're picking up this rook and as you
said no more at f3
Oh Knight f3 will ya I'm not even satis
I'm going for the steak I'm not going
for the chicken I'm going for the filet
mignon right here and this one's over
and look at the time situation beautiful
time management by alina here you greedy
greedy men I've heard you there I don't
think that you could just slip in a I'm
going for the fancy meal look when I go
to Outback and everybody orders a six
ounce steak that's like night take c2
I'm going for the 12 ounce I'm going for
the Knight f3 chat steak I'm not I'm not
there to just to just have a little
small cut of meat well I don't eat meat
anymore but if I did I would hope that
you'd have like a porterhouse for two
that way you get the you know the really
big meal and also you're sharing with me
so I just wanted to be Robert yeah
unique you alright well I only share
with good commentators sorry oh wow okay
well in that case I'm gonna go back to
talking about the chest you can go talk
about your food and how hungry you are
but this position Danya with the fish
one be seven so this is one of those
advantages of capturing on d5 fish won't
be seven it's behind its own pond not
the end of the world does help allow you
to play more than 94 at some point but
the bish one be seven not exactly an
active piece and it won't be for the
foreseeable future
exactly I I think objectively these
positions are equal but I'm always
biased toward the white here because I
feel like Elena's got these your play as
you mentioned that Bishop on be 795 now
comes in just so you know that
relatively small but stable space
advantage I feel like white has a Marge
all practical advantage but maybe 96 and
black and neutralise the initiative with
a couple of accurate moves although
white can always just retreat this
bishop play pawn to f4 and reinforce
that knight on e5 because black is sort
of gasping for air in a position like
this you have no peace except for your
pawn on d5 past the third rank and as we
point out already and we should continue
to mention the bishop when b7 not a very
useful piece so Bishop f3 played is that
really going on for the d5 pawn that
pawns well-protected so I'm not sure I
love Bishop f3 I didn't really love my
dear bishop g3 and poni for either but
somehow the bishop on f3 feels like it's
you're not doing the most yeah I mean
it's looks nice you know finishing the
architectural designs that Bishop on f4
bishop on f3 but I agree with you Robert
I think that pawn on d5 um there's this
this sort of semi famous chess
expression bad bishops defend good pawns
yeah I think it was coined by this this
Romanian Grandmaster Shuba and this is a
good example of that that bishop on b7
is is kind of the unsung hero of blacks
position I'm not seeing you know what
Alina exactly is accomplishing by
putting her fishpond f3 I mean I think
this is in the realm of equality but I
feel like erik has solved most of his
opening problem so maybe there's still
some pressure going on I don't know she
just laughs a touch like wait you would
you save a d5 pawn being protected I'm
going right after it because Queen b3
here putting another there it is another
attacker on that d5 pawn does black have
to make a move like c6 yikes that's not
a pleasant move to play where can you
get away with some sort of 94 and a
certain moment you kind of have to do
something you can't just sit so pass to
the c6 looks awful it might be okay it
can be justified by a silicon beast but
not by me and there's 94 I like that
moving after Bishop 67 you must take
with the rook on me so don't hang the
pawn on d5 when you take the Queen there
and said take with the rook on you 7
yeah and I think black is okay there
I think luck is okay after rook Esau
because you know Bishop takes you for de
one could argue that the knight is
better than the bishop but you know
operatively speaking I'm not sure that
that positional advantage is
particularly significance I like is down
here here great idea
there should be four de it should be
seven I assume Queen e7 or Riki seven
Mirchi 7 well maybe maybe we should be
for Indy 500 I can keep keep the
pressure going or something like that
well I wanted to go after Queenie 7 go
Knight d5 and just oh it might work some
d1 on c1 never mind take it back I'm
like what this works on d1 why is this
real gun D one that works we had seen
one when there's a pawn on c7 it really
a rook c1 and d1 is the ideal setup
maybe we'll see what maybe Rick c1 but
that's what she does I was so just like
in my own head and this rook was already
on c1 because you know the rook on d1
wasn't being so useful and that she did
go over D to C 1 which is strategically
sound but maybe tactically dubious
because look at Eric go g5 is the
geography 6g for Queen h4 going for
really an aggressive Pope approach by
Eric yeah I've lost a lot of these games
just lulled into a sense that you know I
have free pressure my king is safe and
it is for the time being but we can see
how quickly eric is piling up King g7 he
opens the H file and all of a sudden the
fortunes turned completely so Elena's
got to be very very careful 92 okay
she's doubling on the C file but I'm not
sure White's play on the Queen side is
weighty enough to justify you know not
attending to the safety of what
long-term safety White's King although
the night on g3 is an excellent defender
because if I can safely plant my net in
the square and I cover the h1 square
even who checked me on h2 I just run my
king at King f1 King into the center
sounds for those of you who are less
experienced King Randor Center we talk
about my coach always says Castle
picture King safety but if black work of
all of his forces over on the Kings side
sometimes your King's got to go in a
nice little sauntered towards the center
indeed I mean aleena piling up on that C
file the problem is you would love to
put a third rook on c4 right now so if
this were I don't know crazy house game
or bug house game okay the sorbonne cows
game black would also put a queen on h2
and that would be that but you know what
I mean in a certain sense Alena has tied
down Eric's pieces but sometimes people
miss that black is not the only one tied
down White is also tied down to tying
black dot and so as soon as one of the
pieces leaves the C file one of blacks
pieces will also be free I think it's a
very good way of putting in exactly how
I was thinking about it because I
white looks like she is the more
aggressive approach because the pawn on
c7 is the biggest eyesore in the
position but as you correctly stated
that white doesn't have anything going
on for besides the fact that she's tying
black down so it's an idea that income
in fury sounds great but it practices
coming wait what did I just do here I
know I'm 18 now c6 reply there we go yes
c6 and g4 is already maybe not an
immediate threat but definitely a
possibility to deal with no but as you
as you mentioned Robert even if a check
on h2 is allowed it's not over yet
because Knight g1 comes in but still
that looks that looks like white is
hanging you know by the hair on I love
it you stop because you were like oh hey
this is sounds you know listen you don't
hear it as much one except female player
with that expression what do I say so
but you Robert you're always a very good
target for these expressions so I always
rest assured that force comes to worse I
have you well
people miss the hair of my
chinny-chin-chin I've heard it from all
of our fans shout out to all the viewers
here we have so many of you across chest
comm TV twitch YouTube Facebook thank
you so much for joining us on this
Wednesday there's a doubleheader so
don't forget to there's another match
later tonight Eddie what time is it that
8 p.m. Eastern
I think it's 9 p.m. Eastern but don't
crazy sure at the 8 p.m. Eastern you
better not be late because you don't
imagine I'm gonna be very disappointing
I would be a little happy for a bit
because I can just talk about myself
enough to deal with your bad jokes and
your amazing impressions to make me feel
bad that I cannot perfect the Garrigus
bar but this is going to be a full day
ahead and another full day tomorrow of
the I'm not Jim speechless change so I
just want to thank everybody as soon as
I'm thanking people here comes rook
takes c6 with in exchange sacrifice I
love it done you I took it's very
practical decision Elena knows if she
allows that before especially with the
time on her clock she's going to get
checkmate it so very very smart
practical decision absolutely and watch
out for white to play pawn h4 to free up
the f4 square for her Knight because
look at blacks rooks rooks need to be in
coordination with each other play h4 ok
she plays nice to do to shut down the C
file that's probably a smarter choice
because
eita c7 was a threat trying to bring the
rook down the seam line here just rook
to d6 and this rook on d6 on the six men
can shuffle back and forth yeah it's
some serious effort from black to play
d5 before because the a6 pawn will fall
in the interim so I think Eric should
press for a win especially considering
his time advantage but it's not going to
be easy no and you know the King on g7
has been to the g6 fun alena might add
some heat with g4 and she goes g3 which
is I guess sensible is I just don't see
how as you said black and organize this
d5 pawn push and for the third time we
see this happening where it seems like
Eric's pressuring pressuring pressuring
but at some point Elena finds a very
practical resource to change the course
of the game and then all of a sudden she
starts seizing the upper hand but I
agree I think Eric's gotta find some way
here to to muddy the waters a little bit
he decides on b5 I like it I like the
bravery here he can actually take on
before after 80 because ninety five is
not a fork well it is but rook c1 check
gets him out of it
well I'm not sure I like ninety five we
would be on 383 push that pawn to be 300
that pawn on b2 if it falls the game is
over right and b3 c2 rotates be - I
don't know how white plans to stop that
but it's looking pretty nasty Oh hmm if
you want to tell me on the set Oh
checkmate
does it just know there's guy defense
rook h1 other up to g1 with checkmate
Wow and the King can actually escape the
checks on h6 King f8 or oka King g7 or
k7 King h6 that's that's great thinking
by Eric to realize that even though it's
an endgame you can still mount a mating
attack and oh this 97 check where's the
king going okay okay
95 king D six I guess there's enough
space yeah there's enough space again 96
here still but okay yeah William for a
black completely it is winning we're
going to see rook g1 rook h1
rook B to G one with a mate so you can't
stop this exact plan and if we don't see
it on the board I will come back and
show it's a don't worry everybody check
me we'll be on the board no matter what
Alina I think
resign here because nobody likes to
actually see them there can get made it
but in nice big for yourself Robert
don't you lie to the viewers you do not
like it yeah no I there's few things I
hate more than getting checked Minh and
there we see the resignation but please
show it okay so as soon as they start
this next game I will okay they started
next thing I'm gonna pull up this
checkmate here just to to show so any
move that white plays like Knight to c5
there's rook g1 check King age to rookie
to uncheck King G to it
rook B to g1 checkmating this King
because the f2 pawn gets in the way in
the e4 pawn covers the f3 square so it
wasn't working out for Alina and if she
and the start there had tried him
touching her F comic but have four
there's actually this funny check me
Brooke be overlooked see to me as noted
the e4 pawn takes with the f3 square the
rooks do the rest taking away the king's
escape so it's just a check and a mate
so back to this new game we see well I
call it a new game but Daniel we've seen
this line before haven't we deja vu
indeed we've we saw it in is a game that
Elena won but she was hanging by a
thread so this half of this situation
has happened in a couple of the matches
Robin I wonder what you think about it
where there's this dilemma do I repeat
the line that that I prepared before the
match even though you know my opponent
may be as unfair as over-prepared me
there or does Elena shift the strategy
completely is sort of admit defeat it's
a very difficult decision to make in the
course of the games I get the feeling
that erik has prepared this line and
Alina worked it out in the first game if
she loses a game in this line somehow
kind of crushing checkmate down the
h-file she was stopped playing because
yeah it's the type of thing where it
worked out the first time you have happy
memories of it it wasn't clear how I
lose the game and I actually outplayed
my opponent and won a nice Taxco affair
so let's try it again but as soon as
something happens with rook h6 just
another book to H 1 of rook takes H 7
you get checkmated you're like nope none
of that anymore even if it objectively
there's a fight just emotionally you're
like no I've had it that hurt and 94 so
this night trying to come to be
three now what Bishop takes g6 as
possible first of all I wouldn't do that
necessarily because F G yeah that's a
bad move I I forgot about FG but only
number tricky in these but how about
something like queen up before I guess
the night king can can go to f5 and
that's a that's a pretty nice defense of
square stopping Queen h4 if she decides
very bravely an IB 3 o yes o Knight a5
I'm gonna pull down the analysis board
really quickly this Knight f5 move
because night at five I sure she was
just a worried about a capture on f5
then Bishop f5 e f5 then some kind of
rook h6 opposite colored bishop
sometimes give you good chance to hold
but not what an attack just by brute
force comes it looks really tough to
deal with that's a great point Robert
obviously colored bishops people assume
as they produce George tendencies but
with the Queen's on the board it can be
it can have the opposite effect there is
a very famous game between Kasparov and
Karpov really you know I understood its
record for play but getting into a
political official position then I cross
tomb you know with the Queen's on the
board so it can be the exact opposite
because the bishop has no colleague to
contest his control over the over the
diagonal so Knight b3 again very
interesting chance going to c5 alina
again starting to muddy the waters this
Queen h4 h5 resource constantly recurs
these positions right and creates for
here as you point out h5 it's just such
an annoying thing that white has in her
back pocket it looks like just grants
for hey I'm gonna go check meet you on
h7 and I think because a lot of players
are afraid to sacrifice material they
don't think about this move h5
necessarily as being one that is okay
for black but even if black were not a
pawn up to start with giving up a pawn
in this manner tends to work out so
let's say right now we see Queen h4 so
Queen h4 h5 gt86 pompous on even if
black were not up now even because you
start up a pawn this kind of a helps
black survive where if you take on h4
put your king on h7 there's no more
attack and then with the attack dealt
with black and folks in the Queen's back
side and try to get counter play there
mm-hmm yeah well explained and and here
we see rook aged six which Eric also
played in the previous game in this in
this because
at some point Rock aged six because he's
got to stop this age five idea we have a
very similar type of position actually
so it's going to be decided on on these
concrete details can can black find a
way to patch together some some defense
against Queen h4 Eric thinking about
Queen h4 very seriously here yep
because Quidditch for sacrificing the
bishop the bitumen d3 can now move but
rook takes h7 followed rookie Jake check
is not just a check at least to me so
Bishop f5 after let's say Queen h4 if we
just analyze a little bit Queen h4 and
it was just played if there is some kind
of Bishop f5 or Bishop c2 trapping the
rook on d1 rook takes h7 and I see no
way to stop for KJ and green h6 check
there we have it and by the way we think
international master John Bartholomew
for the generous raid John of course
playing tomorrow I mean a very
anticipated match against mr. Trent so
thank you to John hey guys it's John for
the for the for the raid and here will
be sequin h4 f5 now this is not the end
of the story because even after EF Queen
f7 that defense of construction Robert
is surprisingly difficult to break down
it is in the reason why is what is this
dark squared bishop which you know
sounds good looks good but watch out for
this night this night is about to be a a
wily piece there comes to c5 and it's
going to eat for the number throw my
Brooke a to c8 and unless you can get
this rook on d3 over to the H file to
take this h7 pod and even when you do
that I will simply play rook a7 to
protect this is it kind of like I don't
know an impenetrable fortress but it is
very difficult to crack it impervious to
everything but water yeah and maybe the
fastest way to try to get the rope to
the H files to play rook III here not
rogue do you want in you to rock h1 at
rookie 3 then move the bishop from g3
and then try to play her cage to but as
you point out Robert even if you do that
Black has rook a 7 if worse comes to
worse and once again white encounters
the situation he's got physically no
more firepower to put on the Kings side
rook t1 Eric wants to lift his King up
to the e2 square and bring that rook
over but look at Elena's doing
she's just pointing out that
hey if okay sevens always an idea you
can take this pawn on e5 now and
actually I'm I'm wondering if you should
but Bishop e5 runs its rook a two-year
ft8 one of these roads f4 comes you play
ninety seven so you do snag that Bishop
and if that some pieces are getting
traded in the black
rooks gain legitimate activity then you
just see a position where hey I mean
things my fizzle out and there's some
opportunity for black to take advantage
of the fact that White's King site is
overextended what do I mean by that this
pawn on g5 will not be easy to defend in
many lines so if the center collapses
perhaps the King side will also collapse
next yeah very interesting practical
chance by alina for sure so if it should
be five of course rookie aid is not when
the bishop did you have four um and now
i was i was thick oh would you and there
was a real t45 on friday i was thinking
about it I knew it I could just sense
you just know I can't resist those
things but I don't think it quite worked
and Eric's Queen h2 reinforcing the
bishop on e5 but now I'm on other things
aleena could consider taking twice on e5
yes and I'm gonna have it do it look and
analyze this line because this is really
interesting moment here and what Danya
is saying is white is going to get two
routes for the Queen and after 95 fe5
rookie five check Queen e5 rook e8 y can
actually throw in Brooke takes d5 to
steal your central pawn first and I
think that's a good pun to capture
because normally I would take on d5
because your queen on e5 is pinned but
here if I take on d5 and lose the
defense of my rook on e85 to rookie five
check rook takes e5 Queen c4 at best
black is going to make a draw somehow
but rook e8 check worked back to e7 with
check is this hold a little does black
have enough checks for that Queen I'm
not certain
not sure yeah but Elina goes for a
different butch queen e6 after rook h7
Queenie five black is probably actually
believe it or not winning because you
cannot capture the Queen because the
rook is no longer supported on h7 erik
very sensibly goes Queen King f1 now
after Queen takes e5 there might be some
sort of f7 check in the air although I'm
not sure
that doesn't that actually works out
after King up seven right Queenie v f7
King yes in rotation objecting g8 and IV
updates were covered somehow alina has
mastered dark-squared control in these
games in the black side she's making so
much out of her Queen it's always
defending that h8 square it's
unbelievable racino sort of tenacity and
precision and defense by alina goes
Queen g4 very brave but is it good after
rook takes d5 I don't like the move but
rook d5 is she trying to rely on so
gonna rip d8 in a counter checkmate idea
but rook takes h7 there and I never fear
right hmm look you won though by Eric
which I understand the problem is
White's King can tuck itself away on h1
that's a very annoying defense of square
okay 7 Siemens forced and she does have
a blockade on e6 but he placed e6 anyway
oh great Oh an idea Oh completely
overlooked by Elina
I don't understand why she didn't take
on e5 but now that she didn't take on e5
her position is just completely busted
f7 check is pretty brutal and for the
over 8000 of you watching across all the
platforms you see what happens when you
don't take a free point sometimes greed
is good Gordon Gekko will be happy to
hear that I said that but you know the
times you get punished here the
reticence kind of saying maybe I
shouldn't go for that pawn but there's
time 3 seconds but it should be enough
because the position place is so 25 very
practical move f7 me is a humongous
threat I just don't see it effect if
there was some way to prolong the game
but rook f7 for example simply takes f7
and then white crowns a new queen and
it's just Chuck made but uh Eric praying
to the internet gods right now I mean
that's why I hate bringing myself to
this time situation because as good as
spectrum or AT&T is occasionally there
are glitches yes and og 6 how many pawns
you need on the six rank Wow three of
them this reminds me of this classic
game McDonald who gets all the little
adjust everything collapsing work you
say we could have taken any 60 mediums
but Eric Eric being an evil man it's
funny because you change your thought
mid-sentence for a second I thought you
know how to pronounce the last name of
McDonald's opponent oh yeah but you just
like change you focusing on the game all
of a sudden so it sounded like you just
you just were one of those people like
oh yeah that that movie you know that
movie that we all know that that movie
but for those of us in there I don't
know why you it assumes that I don't
know how to pronounce LaBeouf don't know
it's what the elementary and in fact you
should be more worried that I cannot
pronounce English names like and I
cannot pronounce this is oppa is that
abuse but anyways yeah that was a nicely
played game by I think this is the
impetus for Elena didn't change up the
way she responds to Erik's London that
was hilarious I love your impressions
and what we do have many new viewers
here who may not be familiar with the
format
let's call attention to it we have a
time amount of time portion for each
segment here so we have 75 minutes for
the 5 minute plus 1 second increment
portion then we get into the 3 minutes
with a 1 second increment for 45 minutes
and finally 25 minutes of bullet chest
of 1 minute with the 1 second increment
so that's why you see that timer
clicking down the players it's not that
it's the best this minigames your first
so this many wins no it's the timer so
as we saw in the first round Anya even
if you're down for games as long as
there's time ticking on that match clock
you have a chance to come back yeah and
I really like that format it it
encourages the sort of fighting play
that we've seen and literally all of the
mattress so far sometimes when you have
a point target that you need to get to
these considerations of oh you know I
need to draw this game that game and 94
interesting but but that comes into play
here it's just play and play and play by
the way Bishop 67 here got distracted by
that tactic
I think Eric might have overlooked that
move yep and as we yeah this this attack
there it is
you found it and so it is she and that's
just a pawn and with that pawn to d6
pawn is also going to be permanently
weak the d5 pawn also
[Music]
loses its friend I don't know what to
call it
okay becomes Iceland why can't I just
say things as simply as they should be
said the d5 pawn is now in isolated pawn
there it is done you're sorry for
totally butchering you know the good
line that you're proposed you're
forgiven
thank you I'll be nicest for once in my
life yeah and I mean this is just as you
say this isn't just any pun the problem
with these setups for black is is you
make one blunder like this and it's just
total misery
Ericka's ah he's not gonna resign and he
has no tricks with Knights a piece III
because you know why can Y can be
Russian school just take cont c3 with
the rook and say you know what no
tactics I'm just gonna win all of your
pawns now a Knight takes e4 and Knight
c3 or Knight g3 it's just absolutely
miserable position for black if he loses
to the d5 pawn the game is basically
over agreed and its really annoying not
to have that C pawn because I just hope
to move ninety two and my first instinct
was c7 c5 you know something like that
you don't have a seat pawn to ever push
exactly five and challenge for the
center so now white is up a pawn but
like the earlier game we saw where Lina
was actually down a pawn from the white
side if Eric can somehow get some trades
the bishops are strong with the nice
especially this Bishop on d6 or this
Bishop on d6 it is operating on the
Queen side just covering certain squares
and also going to H you do not take on
b6 please please do not take Queen
things b6 do not pass go do not collect
$200 d arick just so tricky and we all
know the extent we all know the rosin
trap that involves stalemate which of
course happens in his previous match but
Elina on top of the situate for though
it just seems a little bit flimsy maybe
she wants some Bishop e1 Bishop a 2 but
Eric has managed to get his pieces into
the game and keep that on on g5
incredibly well protected yeah and
actually you said Bishop be one Bishop
a2 for Eric bishop be Aiden some kind of
Queen d6 lining up on the diagonal does
make a lot of sense and as we look down
the C file of the Queen's on c2 black
has c4c
c67 I made a move before I get all the
highlights in c4 through c8 is all under
blacks control so what are the Queen and
rip doing there they're on an open file
that's great that's where they should be
but you're not accomplishing exactly
what you would like to it I think Queen
e2 needs to happen but not when does a
rook on e8 and allowing it and Knight up
for someone good point you want to go
after this a six point if that a6 pawn
were pushed if you had to go a five then
you give me the be five square for my
bishop and if I guess are trading your
pieces on the Queen side then I'm going
to infiltrate right if you trade all
ropes for example why it's gonna be an
amazing shape but Bishop see it I really
like threatening Bishop takes h3 and you
know Eric is is tempting Elena to to
just you know lie in her pockets on the
Queen side but that King side that King
safety beginning to bother me queen c6
very very good move because rookie six
there's Queen take c8 I really like that
idea because it also stops Queen d6
Bishop takes h3 I'm not sure how Eric
responds to this maybe Bishop e6 just
jettison all the Queen side pawns go
full-on trying to get King side counter
play but that's not easy either no I
don't believe in that I mean I like the
kind of the thought process you have and
saying I can't afford to trade Queens
Bishop d6 similar idea but this actually
protects the pawn on d6 and on it
because once more don't take that pawn
on d6 that's been the theme of this game
and do not take the b6 pawn or else
there's a discover check can I go Bishop
d7 now yeah I do not take what about the
d5 pawn then this ship takes a four aha
yeah Queen takes d5 I think you have two
Queen c2 just retreat admit that what
you've gone for it hasn't quite worked
out but then the a6 point is under
attack this is the problem for both
sides on the C white went in with Queen
to c6 but it has to go back because the
a4 pawn is B but now the Queen's go back
to C to the a6 pawn is weak and if you
want to go a five I will gladly play
Bishop b5 and finally at long last I'm
ready to take over squares in your queen
side
yup and that night on g2 supporting the
knight on f3 stopping you know these
undermining tactics that Bishop takes h3
I agree with you I just don't see how
Eric is going to orchestrate
any sort of counter plan rookie ADA's is
a sign of the times you know the game
again the game is not over white still
only has a fun but if Elina yeah Queen
b3 accumulating the pressure and Erika's
withdrawn most of his pieces from the
Kings side so maybe doubling on the C
file I'm not exactly sure what the best
way is of improving the position for
white I'm considering a pawn sack with
95 just to say you know you're annoying
me with your Bishop on d6 is a good
piece and King h1 trying to take on b6
that is a greedy move King h1 I kind of
actually I don't really like it but I
was gonna say I kind of like it just
because wait Jordan Belfort somewhere is
approving of this movement now 95 yeah
we afraid of Bishop takes h3 ideas well
she is making the prudent move because I
was also ready to give up the h3 pawn
but it does give black a quick attack so
Bishop f1 safe and sound you are up upon
95 is not style g5 g5 I'm Eric's gotta
he's got to go for it here because 45
seconds I feel like he's got to start
going g5 g for throwing all of his chips
and otherwise she's gonna get pushed off
the board but now I think it's too late
too late yeah as with most things I say
day late enough no it's it's a day late
and a dollar short
or is it yeah I think that's what it is
I thought you know you're such a worldly
man you were gonna use different
currency but you became us-centric I
guess uh-huh
yeah I was gonna say a euro a Euro late
and a dollar no oh my god
no no night early in a euro short yeah
there we go
look at you changing up the the idiom
there and well black is struggling to do
anything the knight moves d5 falls the
beef up on still week 96 is a good
attempt but even f4 I guess enter f4 the
black wait d4 it just needs some kind of
counter play and just making White's
King feeling a little less safe is it a
good way to try to achieve that Don yeah
I wasn't really noticing that Lina's up
two full minutes in the clock yeah I
just noticed that is well that is
absolutely crazy I mean two minutes to
13 seconds and this is where you know
Elena's able
to reap the benefits of her time
management she can take 3045 seconds
make sure she finds the most precise way
to realize the advantage but Queen takes
d5 Knight takes e5 surprisingly black
kinda holds things together
Bishop c6 becomes a threat Eric is
annoying in that way he's always able to
find ways to keep extending the game
mission chief or another example of that
I didn't like Knight f3 I thought she
was gonna play f4 and just trying to
protect the pawn in that way but now
Bishop e4 is super annoying if I'm able
to take on f3 I'm hurting your king said
I guess Queen d5 did fall right now and
I sort of forgot that the Queen protects
f3 Knight Queen f3 ends white should be
able to with that pawn on d5 can also be
a vacuumed up potentially although you
know 4 it could defend it but blacks
position starts to fall apart here yep
and Bishop takes b5 can't you one-eyed
then it makes sense because I guess they
have to fajn was hanging after we the d8
I've moved now but should be 5 I guess
yeah that's a bad time steal that thing
gotta turn that vacuum cleaner on it and
then there's yeah there's some
background issues she takes the Queen
but I guess Queen a4 here but then it
takes B - yeah I didn't like Queen
things b5 huh Brooke b1 then just yeah
the thing is the Queen can retreat to
eat them maybe rugby 7 okay I'd like for
very fast
I like your p7 there so the way you win
a position like this is you go after the
f7 point it takes a lot of time and a
lot of effort but when your opponent's 5
seconds left and I like they attempt to
tray Queens there because even without
the Queen's you have some fun is still
such a weakness and then white expands
with E for f4 g3 you know start pushing
your pawns towards your enemy okay and
just limit that night the men on g6
should not be allowed some kind of
aggressive outpost and let's see how do
we how do we finish this Tanya rook d5 I
like that move it's a great move I mean
I think Harris got to play Queen d7 I
mean at some point it's gonna bite the
bullet and trade Queens but defending
that with three seconds on the clock is
all but impossible and Oh time just g3 I
agree with you Robert slow but surely g3
h4 then a
five black is just too passive and the
whites king is perfectly safe there's
just no sources of counterplay I don't
think Galina should be afraid of playing
a move like g3 moving up on in front of
prom king she's going for f4 I guess I
mean King H - it seems to evidence that
is the F pawn is weak so f4 rook
air-five
yeah time just Bishop b4 Bishop t5
another idea - to tighten the screws
alleviate I don't you have to but we
talked about this still should be
excellent for white don't allow 97 do
not allow 9700 okay let D okay you wrote
me that broke is in some trouble -
Brooke Apple three
yeah but take sense you guys I would
take on d5 live rook da King FA just
trying to get my king there I don't like
what I just did I think he had to
without chief five okay and he is king
f3 Rena King in yep all these week King
III enough for a huge idea that rook oh
he goes up seven assists came over this
is Gigi and she paused long wait watch
out Diana the h-bond doesn't match the
bishop so what black needs to do is
trade off the night Oh if you a gia for
ready would have been a draw that would
have been a drug very good point by the
way now f5 comes in and this yeah it's
too late now pushing for the white king
t5m Bishop e1 I mean oh yeah sure about
that but still winning I'm sure Oh
winning okay she didn't disorder bikini
five oh my god oh that was that was
close she cut it close yes and Eric is
just the ultimate swindler
he really is I mean in here there's
there isn't even any stalemate ideas
king of fate and pre-move Queen g7 oh my
gosh that scared me I think we should
pull that one up on the analysis board
while they start the opening of the next
game July hello that moment once more
because we had several different ideas
going through a head and what I was
saying was if Eric had taken on f4 GF
before and then night g6 first 'if I've
would not have been a good move because
95 f e5 king e5 the king sits on h8 and
this way I always bring up Bishop and
rook pawn look
the corners match this would be a
theoretical drawing spot so just
something to keep in mind for everybody
who's tuning in Alena would not have
played e5 should have held off let us go
to the live game we don't want to miss
any of the live action you take him on
e5 Ali and she had to because Bishop g6
h4 is typical idea forcing black to ruin
her pawn structure with h6 so Eric with
another one of his his lines that that
seemed innocuous but he's gotten a very
good position here the two bishops and a
slightly weakened pawn structure for a
Lina but yes for something like g6 it's
you know no serious damage has been done
and she does the right thing by going
for a long castle I'm pretty pleased for
checked has some counter play I guess
because they see someone is hanging yeah
and aha so but Eric's got to be careful
he's a little underdeveloped so castles
and E 5 here can come very very fast so
I like Knight c3 emphasizing you know
completing his developments interesting
position my first instinct is I don't
really like this pawn 6 because the
backward pawn if white gets a Bishop h3
you have the two bishops as well but
what you just said totally makes sense
to me and Queen before that is how about
a3 a3 a very typical idea Queen B 294
traps the Queen no that's it's a little
bit impulsive I think maybe she wants to
tuck her Queen on b6 in order to pave
the way for Bishop d6 but something
about that seems a little artificial
yeah because why can't even consider
Knight d5 type of maneuvers forcing the
rook to see a meadow I can't go in I'd
be fine now but if Queen b6 was playing
with fire maybe 4 leaves the Queen with
one square yeah Queen B 690 do I trap
the Queen 9 a fork oh my goodness no you
didn't Queen c6 b5 the Queen's trapped I
have all of the squares that your Queen
can go to and that's sick in the center
of the board like that Wow
and Alina realizing it sheet but it's
too late to back down now she's just
down a P I mean this is just completely
completely losing hey I told vid of this
I have to tell you the same thing we're
not using language like that especially
when air rosin as well I don't care what
side of it nothing is completely losing
when Eric Rosen
what that's photo on a serious note this
is really really really bad for black
okay down a piece and and it's not just
the thing is you might saw well black
has two bonds for the piece the problem
is first or rugby one or takes P sevens
possible and second of all black still
has a pretty weak King so you know why
it's got all of these advantages in
there it's got plenty of time so rook
could be one sensible I think Eric is
actually pretty good at converting
advantages like this but we all know
Elena's tenacity even 94 years possible
so definitely not over over we've seen
swindles and worse positions than this
that's for sure
Bishop d3 but these the type of moves
that Bishop III makes sense but also
it's a bit slow are you're not
threatening anything and now c5 comes a
new thing
hey it's my kill anyone actually that's
safe or is there something some kind of
e five breaking everything open you just
get in your own head
eric has plenty of time here you should
convert this and as you said he is
obviously extremely good not just at
defending tough positions but also
converting good positions but we saw in
Game one
Eric was up a pod and that there should
one be seven an item before everything
was going well but he let Alina hang
around for a little bit too long and I'm
just concerned that this could happen in
this game too yep and rook takes P seven
I like that decision by Eric fearless
because c4 looks annoying but after
Bishop e2 I feel like black is no fault
it's also important to point out this
Bishop on f4 defending the BH square
that's a huge source of counter play for
black otherwise that is now completely
shut down there's no route b8
possibilities so you know white pieces
are kind of doubling as very good
defenders I just I'm just not seeing it
for black here in terms of you know
whipping up some sort of last second
kind of play and the rook on g1 the rook
on b7 they pile up pressure on the g7
pawn keeping the 97 stuck there I'm with
you down yet it's just the position that
looks like you don't have any of the
real resources you need to hold such a
tough position maybe just like c4 Queen
86 started take this rook off the
seventh ranked event
eventually push our a poll and you need
some idea you do the positions bad so I
hope lacy fourth Bishop e2 Queen a6 the
rook moves somewhere I try to
see six try go a five and get something
going for me I know it's not a lot I
still hate my position but something at
least is available to you in those lines
right and you're playing on on the fact
that your opponent can get impatient
it's I've seen many games decided like
this where you're up a piece here you
have some certainly winning position but
no immediate opportunity presents itself
start getting impatient and that's
exactly when when the blunders and the
super impulsive decisions happen so
Elina going for Queen a one rugby one
Queen a5 I guess but after that there's
this 94 resource that essentially might
force some sort of a trade that has to
has to be favorable for white 94 is a
good move and this is themed attic when
you see Queens in the same diagonal you
often want to remove the piece that's
separating them especially when you're
up material as Eric is here 94 exposes
the Queen on a 5-2 an attack and then
maybe lean over the Queen a to live see
before maybe yeah just you know you just
just Ryan just go for your resources and
Eric is up on the the clock I actually
thought that Alina spent too much time
to play Queen in one check show in a
minute and a half when you're down a
piece and you're trying to fight back
you need to have an advantage in the
clock you need to put your opponent on
trouble and Eric with two-plus minutes
here right that's not the kind of time
trouble that would make me concerned
about his ability to convert this
decision yeah that's a great point I
think you have to try to exploit every
advantage you have and playing fast when
you're lost it can also tempt just
psychologically tempt your opponent into
blank fast as well and and you have
nothing to lose if you lose the game you
know I was already lost to begin with
but you've got to use every practical
tool to complicate things in the book
Erik take it wisely taking his time here
deciding on the appropriate course of
action but he can't fall asleep entirely
and goes up three but 10 surely I mean
just covering the Foursquare general of
proving move and rook up 7 to
preemptively protect g7 so there's no
timely Bishop h6 or Queen g2 swinging
the Queen over there and I mean it looks
really burning serious clock now and yes
I don't like f3 Dania is if knight eh
five comes the f3 pawn is a target
mm-hmm it already lose how easy
positions starting to look a little bit
loose yeah Black has really picked up
some momentum here and rook b5 there's
Queen a3 I'm just hanging on by third I
can take on d3 to check as well okay so
tonight here Queen hmm I like that move
King F shoe there's already some oh I
know you were looking at the same thing
I was with problems down the epilogue
with E 5 5 oh goodness
Bishop e5 94 check takes Knight takes
and oops there goes the Queen
the problem was King F to e5 there may
have been row K 1 but now we'll see
another very good now Knight takes c3
and rook c2 is all of a sudden the
threat eric is almost down to a minute
man I am this is looking pretty darn
good for Alina I mean of course white is
still completely winning and Eric should
win this game but she's done a great job
complicating the situation
hey done are you hungry because you
should probably eat your earlier words
just just throwing that out there
mm-hmm aye-aye-aye visit how about steak
house might be on the card all right so
how do we get a 5 to happen right we
need to play e5 is black if we're gonna
try to sometimes but I really like
Eric's 194 a lot it just now challenges
black the last few moves black was one
picking momentum seizing the initiative
and 94 is fighting back for it and the
e5 square I can just plant my Bishop
there at the right moment play pawn F 3
to F 4 gain some more space on the King
side and black somehow needs to make a 5
happen I just don't see away yeah and
that's 94 was just a complete
showstopper it's one of those moves
where you start getting hopeful and and
your opponent just brings the hammer
down and that the fact that he 5 is
defended is is the critical factor here
in this position now that being said I
like a 6 alline kind of H were making
rookie aides
I don't know how to how to spice things
up here for black I feel like galena's
exhausted most of her immediate
resources here what about some kind of
knight Age 5 597 yeah just ask you where
you're gonna put that bishop
the rookie I played so going for a five
and now look at the time done you're 40
seconds for Eric he's shown that he can
play with just three seconds on his
clock but this is really not that easy
up dish that I could take on d3 and go
for a five on one I would like maybe in
Queen a3 at some moment just to hope
that you blunder your fish 26 to
Discovery's 97 mm-hmm this should be fun
97 97 yep okay this is really starting
to turn around yeah mazing because wife
is still up a piece actually King e2 in
this position would have been
interesting trying to trap the Queen but
F for now night C find out easy for
squares week as well look at the time 24
seconds steadily taking down ternary 94
now okay Brooke see a track take a d-pad
you get that idea
Brooke g2 though root t2 is a nice hard
move to play I would say but a really
nice move because when you see an open
g5 you know that's swing your Queen dg2
to checkmate of rook g2 covering the
second-ranked
in bishop age 7 he wants night she find
that f7 I looked at that wasn't sure
it's that convincing well actually how
do I keep my Brooke on c8 safe ooh
King F a queen g2 and then Knight takes
e5 and you could plan for a few more
moves but it actually was a really nice
tactical it really was good Eric just
taking a knight of fate Bishop d6 then
Knight other Knight to d7 yeah but the
problem is the white king is all of a
sudden quite safe funny one agreed so I
just feel like Queen g7 and White's
pieces are streaming and Knight cd7 no
threatens rook takes you to stuff so you
have to be a bit careful
yup check and Queen f7 chef and f7 and
rook takes a fade and that's all she
wrote
is this what kind of Queen eight Queen
the Queen 83 would be a cool move but
you're east exam which I can see a
Brooks hanging with Jack I'm trying to
go Queenie three tasty three yeah kind
of a fork but yet what blacks thing is
just too weak your Queen a5 and white
skin can run to g1
right yeah and this one is there's c3
very sensible move out of checks and the
game is over Queen c8 just don't blend
her to check in enough to
and Eric wins on time Danya that game
was way closer than I would thought it
would be uh yeah you had said at first
you're like oh this game is over and I
said wait a second here they're still
gonna be some complicated matters well
that goes to show that you you have to
win one games and winning one games is
when the hardest things to do in chess
only one of us can be Nostradamus here
so I defer to you in that regard but I'd
also point out I think it's something
they say you know in basketball
sometimes it's a lopsided game and you
know you're gonna win the game but it's
still worth making a run because you
basically it's chess is also a game of
psychology so now for example Eric might
the next time he reaches a winning
position you might be a little bit
unsettled remembering that he had a very
difficult time winning it the last time
so it's not only about the immediate
result when it comes to a long match
it's also about instilling the sort of
psychological fear anyway we have an
idea this is the Casa Corley yep against
by Cinco this is the Casa court it is
gonna be oh my gosh this was like one of
the games of the year
yup in 2019 from the extra con formerly
the politican Cup in Denmark Fe for this
night age three Czech gh3 Queen takes h4
with all sorts of fancy rookie five type
moves in to age three pawn oh boy and
Eric just taking that move in taking
that sip of his I wonder what T that is
grapefruit green tea yoga Zen tea but he
has really gotten the Rose n of this
position this is again that maybe some
of the viewers are familiar with the
brilliant women by Casa Corley and we
see him reproduced here I'm very mad at
you for that pun i didn't i didn't miss
it I heard it
thank you as long as you heard it Robert
then that makes me satisfied already
we're gonna show a five rook takes e5 d
e5 Bishop c5 check the King is running
out of squares and if you go to g2 or h1
ISIL queen takes Asia to me you had to
make them look like 94 then try to block
with rook f2 but you've already
sacrificed so many pawns just to win the
rope to begin with that black is going
to be the one in a favorable position
I do believe somehow somewhere there
might be some kind of like draw
miraculous draw but I don't know it and
coming up with it over the board is not
going to be fun indeed especially
my Cinco didn't finds the solution of
classical game and I think there was a
correspondence game a few years back
where where this happened but in terms
of over the board play
I think Costas move was was a novelty so
no I actually think cause it played it
twice I think he'd be too different GM's
with the line or something that makes my
looms but either way Kasich poorly
uncork this here's rookie five and Eric
Rosen look at that a student of the game
and there's you think that we've talked
about in the past onion I want to
reiterate it now because we take
friendly barbs of the players and it's
very difficult to place speech as no
matter who you are no matter what your
rating is but Eric has clearly studied a
lot he is prepared not just for this
match but in general and I have to give
him a shout out because you know he's
looked into this line and Alena clearly
not familiar with a game because you
don't walk into this from the white side
if you are and I just want to give a
shout to arable focus on the chest and
more but good on you air pros I agree
with you Robert and and here he's got a
she got to be precise but I think Queen
g5 check and Bishop takes you for is
taking his time I have exactly the same
thoughts that you do in terms of Eric's
just studious nough siz diligence and
approaching opening preparation he's
just he's a hard worker and and he reaps
reaps the rewards in terms of his
opening preparation we see time and time
again she's reaching very dynamic
positions he knows what he's doing
and it's really refreshing to see
someone with that kind of work ethic
when it when it comes to openings I just
think white is completely busted here
after Bishop g4 Bishop takes you for
that King is just like too wide open
there yeah this is this is dunzo and i
know i typically don't like saying that
but here this is much more clear than
some of the other games we've seen in
the reason why is the King on g1 is
likely going to be made in a few moves
now I just take a free roll viola Fiamma
this is over go take with the rooks I
think with the bishop I don't know
either one should be completely and
utterly winning and as mentioned the
King on h1 so we hear black will be up
three pawns after capturing on f5 yeah
just completely busting and the best
kinds of attacks are the ones where
you're up a ton of material and you're
attacking bishop
five mm-hmm we've got five is a little
more prudent but this is this has got to
be completely work III just resigned but
what I was gonna ask you
it should Elina use the entire mass
clock in terms of a five-minute portion
here or should she resigned and get one
more game if you were Elina what would
you do I would resign and get one more
game I would try to because I mean I
don't think it has that much
significance necessarily but I wouldn't
I feel like if you waited it out you
would have this bad taste in your mouth
and I would resign and sort of test Eric
and maybe a different opening but we'll
see I mean I think she's honestly trying
to think and find some sort of way to
stay alive checkmate but I feel like
Elina will resign and and go for it for
another game yeah she plays mega g1 okay
there's no Queen g3 type stuff looks
really strong but there's no I didn't
even accumulate the pieces and the
reason why I asked that Danya was
because on one hand as you said you
don't want to go into the next time or
stir with a getting crushed because you
didn't know a line that Eric just said
I've seen this before Kasich or Lee
another I am very strong player
shout-out to him but also what if you
lose that next game that you get you may
get one more game before the time's up
and now you're down three points Eddie
needs a three-minute time segment that's
not fun either
no definitely and arguments can be made
for both sides here you know when you're
when you lose the last two games and
you're down by two that is indeed very
debilitating one thing Alena could also
do during the break is just quickly look
up some of these lines I think that's
that's not against the rules so we'll
see I mean for the time being she she's
trying to stay in the game problem is
literally it's very hard not to win this
game
rook takes c3 is probably the easiest oh
there's rook takes f5 so it's not quite
winning yet but I wanted to remove the
night so I get busy for with mating net
here
Bishop takes h3 is good rook takes c3
dimension is good is there anything
that's not good here probably giving
away your queen for free but other than
that yeah something like Queen g2 check
I think might be you know going we take
h3 check
no that doesn't that's how good blacks
position yeah it's never a good design
when your twin your stroke takes c3 is
immediately winning well that's what I
was saying but rook takes a5 and all
right f5 ok the of it wants to get
to e4 of course
so maybe Bishop g6 just hold off the
roof takes either move from one turn
this you know eric says give me my
fourth extra pawn so yeah at this point
alina was sort of the last chance to
resign start a new game so i guess we'll
see what what strategy she employs
yeah so many meaning nets possibly shove
g2 chat Queen h4 to follow is made I'm
just a bring your other rook in just
mm-hmm
too many options yeah I mean Bishop g2
is just immediate made as you say this
is I feel like Eric can just sit here
and enjoy enjoy life for a little bit
I'm sure he sees all of these wins but
you know he's just savoring savoring
this game in his opening preparation and
time is up so I guess I guess I don't
think aleena decided to milk the clock I
think she's honestly playing now she's
gonna resign them yes after Queen h4
check it's about time you have to block
the night and now you lose your queen
after room g3 she does resign that means
the 5-minute time patrol with that one
second increment is done we have a clear
leader that's Eric Rosen up two games
now over Lina Cashman skya aleena will
have to work on some of these openings
she's not getting the positions she
would like Eric seemed like the better
prepared player on both sides with both
colors here and Anya any final thoughts
with a five-minute segment before we go
to break
well it was all about opening
preparation I think Eric most of the
aleena showed incredible tenacity some
of these games but when all is said and
done Eric's just incisive opening
preparation he reaches the position he
likes especially in this last game it's
a very impressive job on that front
Elina will have to do something about
those openings because she'll have even
less time to mount a resistance you know
when she reaches undesirable position so
we'll see how that all unfolds but we'll
let the players refill their coffees and
take a little bit of a break yeah Lina
was great in three minute or ssin
against Christophe zu lucky so it was
if she could replicate that success in
the meantime everybody stretch your legs
get your brains fresh because we'll have
great chess ahead of us in three minute
or we will be right back
[Music]
and we have this excellent I am now GM
speech a shrimp ship brought to you by
chess calm and we figured hey what
better question asked today then what
other speed Chess Championship should be
included in the SEC series I want to
involve Daniel Niro disky is one that I
would be supportive of so what do you
think Danya any ideas and people get
involve with hash tag speed chess by the
way and should get involved well if it
involves staying on there this kid has
to Bob Robert has as well but there
there are a lot of possibilities in all
seriousness something maybe that
features untitled players but blitz
specialists maybe maybe a collection of
players who you know our NMS or FM's are
lower but very very known to be very
good at blitz and bullet that would be
one thought but I'm very excited to hear
what what people have to say in that
regard and in these tournaments I think
at the very start Robert you know there
were some arguments about well they're
not grandmasters you know what could be
so interesting about that we have seen
one incredibly combating just
edge-of-your-seat match after another so
I think these players have put their
hearts up I am just having so much fun
watching each and every matches it's
really a blessing yeah it's been a
phenomenal start to what has been an
excellent event and this match is no
exception to that we've seen air grows
in G between four and a half two and a
half lead he won his first round matchup
/ le pates and Alina castles got one
that really close match against chess
explained and there's more action to
continue not just in this one but
tonight at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time it's
5:00 p.m. specific I don't know where
you all live viewers but wherever it is
look up the time you should be tuning in
for that matter between leve Rosman
that's Gotham chess and Teddy Coleman
the player who defeated dating French in
the opening round so another good
matchup ahead of us but hey let's let's
go no further than this one they're
playing the three-minute plus one second
increment right now the action is
underway and surprise surprise dunya we
have Bishop f4 on move to my era frozen
first time Erika's ever played that move
really going out on a limb but alina
changing up her strategy this move
Bishop c4 I've seen it before
um it's an interesting option and an
Eric deciding to go with Knight f3
instead of f3 I like what she's done
here this is not going to be you know
Eric he's not gonna come out of the
gates here with the mating attack that
Bishop on g4 tying down that night this
is more more of a positional lion it is
that's where the break comes in really
handy because Alina is down two games in
the match score she's proven to be a
really good 3-minute player but the fact
you can take a breath and then go look
at an opening say this hasn't been
working out for me I'm getting pretty
much checkmated or I feel like I'm the
verge of getting checked in so let me
switch gears and go to something that is
more solid as you pointed out here Ali
no moving very quickly and will be
confidently and moving well because I
actually really like these positions
from the black side especially if you
can make sure that this pawn f4 has to
be thought about from White's
perspective yeah I mean it might appear
that white has a bind going in the
center but with that being said you know
Queen c7 always hits that point at 4y
doesn't really want to play a move like
g3 because that introduces more
weaknesses on the Kings side
I feel like blacks 94 here definitely
Elena has solved her opening problems
and she's got a comfortable position
here but obviously the fight is still
ahead but I definitely think she's
relieved not to be getting checkmated
out of the opening as she wasn't that
line and having to defense with every
ounce of strength he or she can she can
play a little bit quicker and she's not
in the position she likes yeah look at
her move up see very normal move that
has a semi-open file he's put your
Brooke on it and the question now
becomes what actually is blacks plan it
looks like you've staved off White's
plans but do you've any plans of your
own and those are not that easy to come
up with she's looking at b5 mm-hmm
perhaps a before trying to break through
on the Queen side but anytime I see a b5
I can just play a three if I wants to
stop before so it's not that easy for
black to come up with something concrete
just yet if you move this night away
from d7 then f5 is a much more dangerous
threat as you lose the ability to play
east 65 in response
yeah and a for your air it does stop b5
and again asks Alina a question about
what is your long-term plan here how are
you
prove the position my long-term plan in
my shorts our plan is to grab that the
tea that I forgot on my counter so I
will let you take the wheel about seven
seconds Robert well I'm glad that you
can you know make your tea and drink it
too and in the meantime we look at
Elena's Knight c5 coming right after
that pawn to a4 one of the downsides of
pushing your pawn you have may have
stopped blacks plan to go b5 but you put
your paw on a square that it can't be
targeted on now f5 by Eric exactly what
I was anticipating the knight moves away
since there's no longer e5 as a resource
for black and now this is a really
interesting position where the e6 pawn
if it's captured it becomes a real
target whereas if this pawn did not go
to f5 and capture on e6
it would felt like a safe pawn chain
Lina doesn't want to capture at a5
that's for sure you captured a 5 here
comes the Knight to f5 coming into e7 so
Danya and what kind of tea did you make
vanilla something vanilla herbal it's
not a lot of names I feel like Eric
Rosen would like that team it's not
caffeinated which I'm not a big fan of
but I just had a big coffee before this
so just pull it pulling in Eric Rosen
and and trying to be Zen about this or
as Karissa would say you know just say
now I must stay and chill out
Wow well wait way to go sighting
interviews from our players in previous
matches Krissy get will play Greg jihadi
in another quarterfinal matchup but
Donny you look at this you have your tea
you're ready to analyze this position an
annoying thing from White's perspective
is this e six pump looks really weak but
you can't play b4 because then your c3
pawn is equally if not even weaker than
this Pony 6o rookie simply some tactics
here just yeah I'm my sense of time I
mean my alarms are going off but I maybe
you should just double on the e fo but
that seems like a bit of a cop but
there's gotta be some c4
what about c4 I like it c4 just crashing
through before so he decides to go but
what does he wanna 94 does he want to
take on e4 what's the follow up rookie
for de yeah oh here or I really didn't
like before and then he before happens
and he must have been so focused that
Knight takes a four that's a free pawn
you think oh I'm sacrificing
and then your opponent ignores that pawn
and puts the knight in the center where
c3 is really under attack me likey oh
shoot wait a second that was the wrong
way to go yeah this is all of a sudden
threatening to fall apart a pure white
importantly rookie for te night of five
there's a takes f5 counter attacking the
Queen that's a very unpleasant detail
for for Eric maybe f3 ok goes rook t3 is
trying to keep things patched together
but you know if worse comes to worst
Elena can double up on the e-file and
the immediate problem of that e6 pawn is
gonna be resolved right because you
protect east 6 with only piece rook III
though for white so I'm not sure exactly
how resolved it is and the e6 pawn can't
move the e6 front couldn't move a second
ago because the work on CA was hanging
but it still can't move because Knight
f5 forks the Queen on d6 on the roof any
7 so you're a little tied down but f3 is
a weakening move you have to admit that
if you do play f3 and I'd like this move
a 5 now Knight of 6 hits the Queen on g4
it seems like a Miss played position
here for Eric and I eat 6 is protected
take on before steal that power
yeah CD Queen before I mean not only is
the position falling apart the time
situation stop starting to fall apart as
well Queen T is a free point by the way
waited Oh 96 you clean back to b6 I
think now now I mean what's blacks quote
first choice when Queen h4 9h for King
f7 we need 497 checked oh my goodness oh
man wow that's a good tactic there you
get a check in the Queen that is the
grades are captured here now wait a
minute what is what does like do Oh sick
that's brilliant by Aragon and so
quickly - he is just so sharp at these
at these small tactics that's such a
talent of his that makes him such a
dangerous blitz player but still I mean
Oh Lina has got the initiative but that
pot on t3 now becoming a weakness double
on the D file yeah just particularly
yeah this is too slow for black here and
all rook c2 will be just 1 check if you
give me get it how he v e4 was an option
check now he's gonna gobble on b7
but the King on g6 is actually quite say
yeah a good point oh oh now they're real
contagious new second is he doing once
and oh my gosh you feel maybe that's
losing quit now if we do Queen d2 in
June you get a queen oh my goodness and
do you play Queen eight-six's turn why I
always repeat I would go Queen h6 I
would try to flag them okay now in f1
mating there has to Queen of one of the
King h6 or some well or queen G - yeah
95 is also good now she's got a secret
okay now Queenie for waiting for Oh No
King get a six king of six a seven Queen
h4 g5 and Queen H 3 g5 create really
nice and then wow like the O king h5 no
not there
wait how could you stop the politics why
would you happened oh my goodness no way
this is unbelievable can you up to six
doors Oh any promotes McQueen there's
enough when c4 Queenie three four three
two oh my oh my goodness by the last
resource goodness 20 did we just see we
have to pull up the announcement really
quickly because we're freaking out the
players had no time from their clocks
but just to pull up this game really
quickly that last one because earlier in
it Lina was just winning one in the
world she promoted and then she went
Knight to d5 she could have moved her
King first 195 and in 93 and after Queen
e4 to check a seven
she had a go Queen f1 checking gauge for
g5 check cage five clean age three check
and the only way to stop the maids with
Queen h4 and I just simply take you
Queen and your king is going to get me
the next move so unfortunately for Alina
in that critical moment she was unable
to secure the full point and go back to
the live game and she is the white
pieces she's trying to claim space but
Danya that was imagining a mass change
right indeed and even after night of
five there h5 was when Alina just losing
or cool and and that just happened
sometimes you you know we look at it
from the side and we see that she's got
eight seconds we think that's a lot of
time but when you're in the hot seat and
you see your time ticking down that can
lead to some very irrational decisions
that's that's huge that extends the lead
to three and we see Alina is just very
calm very professional but you know her
mind she's she's just got to be you know
thinking some someone pleasant thoughts
and
and it's just so hard to be objective
after something like that and kudos to
Eric for finding that Knight f5 tasty
seven check tactic because you know
we've looked at her position Elena's out
playing him and I think that he sort of
stumbled into a nice tactic he sort of
was getting outplayed that sort of he
definitely was getting outplayed and
then he finds his tactic you know whoa
Eric Rosen watch out but he just didn't
have that much time on his clock and he
was very fortunate that Alena could not
find the knockout blow in and win the
game but right now with the white pieces
Alena is up thirty five seconds and look
at how much space she has this is a
standard opening line it's not like
black has done anything wrong but I just
think that generally speaking you feel
more comfortable with the white side and
notebook at f4 to f5 is an idea that but
it takes a six and B five sorry
interrupter oh it takes a six and B five
I feel like that's was devastating but
then you've rook c8 for black at the end
so I take on b5 Oh
why are you good at chess I'm sick of
commentating with someone who's good
although you might have c6 to start and
then I kicks the night out and then I'd
be fine but you have to always think
deeply about pushing a thief on too much
but it might work out for you mm-hmm so
she's doing it yeah rook c8 though but
very clever I mean I feel like that's
the only move otherwise it's just
crushing yeah I mean Aaron definitely
miss this I think but yeah it looks like
somehow he's black really escaping in
that line though I'm not I'm not sold
just yet so here it comes to Knight b8
played mm that pawn is looking real good
there that night on b5 Tudors cannot
really be dislodged it can be supported
with a four maybe ninety seven ninety
five and a four otherwise it's an
eternal night as as the Russians say or
maybe ninety seven so car you know
trying to UM Oh a little bit okay but
actually in all seriousness how does
white stop night 87 I don't see a clear
way just yet but uh give me a second
I'll figure it out
some kind of yes actually
okay b1 work everyone hangs the h3 pawn
which is what I'm annoyed yeah I was
thinking of sacking doing a rook c6 at
the ends
but I have rook a7 and I just win
yourseif on anyway right so we're yeah
and you've got this if FA is rook be 195
rook b5 Bishop a3 rook c6 and rook a 7
and the point is that after you take on
b6 and there's no background check mate
like you would like to have happen
because the bishop retreats all the way
to FA in that variation so there's a
quick thing to show you all a for played
I like this move because now if you win
b6 the F upon will become weak but the
bishop can land on v4 in many of these
sequences which protects that
potentially of week eight pawns of King
f8 played I not sure I like that whoa
that is just playing with some serious
fire but King e ke eights and he's
taking the d7 square under control
so King e aids for K to be 1 right and
then Knight takes d5 rugby fiber okay
seven wait a second done after King Jia
can I even play Knight to c6 somehow
okay so this is not gonna have takes but
now white needs to be precise ok 797
check King EA and you take on b6 I take
on c7 how convincing is that I don't
feel thoroughly convinced yeah alright
because in the end there's this it'll be
seven move and all of a sudden there's
wait a sec go tonight a for its of rook
takes t7 I think you'd go night a4
uh-huh just threatened b6 you yeah but
rook c1 would be 7th ok she just takes
the pawn I was thinking rook p7 here
mm-hmm
yeah me too and then then R okay Bishop
again this Bishop cover they say Knight
c8 maybe maybe you meet immediately here
yeah Bishop before this is like it's
just starting to crumble for a way
because that pawn on d5 as long as it's
contained yeah oh now that's a nice move
Bishop the 8b 6
mm-hm and it should be for those R okay
okay Bishop to you yeah b6 qingtian no
995 so the King keikogi 7 to d6 and try
to approach that way yeah but King g7
okay 7 exactly exact that's really nice
so the King can't get to d7 oh this
can't be good no King d7 again b7 or 95
Wow very interesting complications
and when it bounced back for Alina be7
first shrink okay check here and then b7
I think Bishop f6 there was a good try
for black instead trying to get around
at the other side Bishop Bishop takes d4
oh good call that pawn is was hanging on
d4 I actually think that might have been
a serious resource but now the problem
is King CC b7 king b5 okay aid and white
takes on ba and goes 97 serve rookie yep
I think this is over
Red Rover unless I'm missing something I
don't think you are usually there's
something I miss but you know what
Eric's gonna do is gonna go Bishop c7
he's gonna sack that Bishop for the
pondo King c4 well don't get it don't
Queen yet so after rook b8 97k before I
can get three you can even Queen and go
Knight to c6 against Bishop c4 oh sure
sure that's actually a really nice way
to protect the pawn so you get a queen
and once we get this quaint and I will
come to c6 at Don you're saying and it's
exactly what's gonna happen
and once the knight gets to c6 it's
going to d8 where it's f7 oh that's
painful
that's a shot to the gut and King f3
very controlled move by Alina the idea
and you just start scooping up the pawns
one by one that pawns not going anywhere
nice g5t for Knight takes c6 also wins
uh hi you sneaky guy so Donnie's trying
to let the pawn go so Knight g5 d4
Knight takes 86 d3 you think that pawns
queening then you have this knight c5
move so I can show that maybe in a
second I will after this game is over
but yeah now one point four seconds left
for Arab Rosen will let em lose oh my
gosh yeah oh my god any he's gonna lose
yeah how did he get that move off I had
some magic so we're gonna pull it up in
the analysis board because I do like
what you just point out dunya there was
a really instructive endgame maneuver
where after we got to this position with
Knight capturing on f7 Knight g5 d 496
d3 it looks like this pawn is just
queening with the help of the king but
done is on Knight to c5 enough for D -
you have Knight e4 check and what you're
doing is sacrificing the night for the
pond and no
you have two extra pawns here for white
and so you just start pushing your pawns
open the game it's a really nice vision
there by you Daniel we're back to the
live board very weird opening yeah a
bishop on b4 a bishop on g4 and Queen to
b3 here just looks like a good move for
white saying hey that Bishop is kind of
hanging over here yeah I think Elena
might have dumped a little little too
much Tabasco sauce on that opening in my
back fire I mean this idea with leaving
that Bishop on g4 is interesting because
that meant 9:00 that night on g-force is
annoying but Queen b3 like you said
Robert I'm not buying this concept
entirely maybe Queen b3 knight c6 is
their plan response because this is
actually somewhat fee Matic if you're a
3 I've 19 to d4 and you can't take my
bishop because I have night c2 forking
the house so next e6 gains you an
important tempo and she plays c5 first
but she strike in the center it's not
like white is developed that's true I'm
skeptical but I'm also you know I admire
the bravery here that night on g4 it's
you know it's it's flimsy but it's also
so annoying just pressuring f2 I'd
really like that move to c5
Oh does something is this just feels so
flimsy for Eric as well cg is actually a
threat now easy Knight takes d4 and you
can't capture that bishop on before
because of a for constancy - exactly so
just to show that you can't take before
still then 92 check devious before or
not d4 looks good to me huh
in fact what do you do after d4 you can
you can't castle because f2 hangs you
can go oh roopd one there's DC 92 Oh see
- and it's a check to the King and there
we see it moving
maybe Eric has to take on d4 go Queen g1
but that can't be good Queen f6 why do
black just mows down all these pieces
after 84 guy just by Queen 64 -
absolutely
Wow I go just right after your f2 pawn
your kings in the center she's and look
at elite no with a recovery after that
incredibly tilts in game just a
composure a great game last round rook
do you wanna play now DC maybe he wants
BC yes
DC DC
your claim is that the Queen on d8
sundar duck even their queen a5 I mean I
don't know if you're really getting away
with this
yeah Queen a 5 is a very strong move I
think this year those suspicious just
say the least
yeah Queen a 5cb night before I just
don't see a way to I mean look at
White's King side you called this Robert
it's you know why does no development
going on the Kings side and and blacks
all of us all of her pieces in the game
you know that's just gonna haunt Eric
here so what is she thinking about is
there some kind of bishops HC no bishops
III doesn't make sense to me so it's
really Queen a5 yeah and that's it I
don't see a downside to Queenie I mean
I'm sure there are some I'm sure there
are some you know resources maybe Queen
a 5cb night before and then just say you
know what King needs you you know it's
the desperate situations call for
desperate measures and sometimes it's
it's hard to actually collect you know
and hunt down the King in the center
like this
there's rook t8 there's Bishop d6 I were
thrown an e5 first for precisely that
reason
exactly great points he five-year was
saying I'm shutting your Bishop off from
the d6 square instead roof d8 admission
d6 and night a6 okay if I can win to c5
pawn yeah you're pinned along the
diagonal your Bishop can't move because
then the Brooke undies which is this
lost 1972 he's a threat now by this yeah
that's actually in the mix of something
like Bishop e2 can be met with Knight
take steps to good tactical I and how do
you actually deal with that I mean this
Knight is a see it looks unassuming
maybe Queen b5 here but then Queen c3 I
you know in my try here dunya is Bishop
d3 Knight f2 castles King side it looks
ridiculous Wow
maybe I have enough compensation somehow
with my bishop pair I feel like that's
what he's going for
that's actually a beautiful idea because
then I actually Queen takes T to rook F
to Queen III this Bishop page 7
exactly and you just might be the Eric
Rosen whisperer we'll see when he does
sick but I don't think it works honestly
it should just be losing their also
Knight takes e5 ideas right so actually
if you Castle kingside Queen d2 rook f2
who can i play just Knight takes e4
I've no I can't because rookie 293 83
roof t6 is Bishop 87 check once more in
this discovery on h7 tells the tale so
he does this which does allow them to
pick up the night the problem here is is
simply Knight takes e5
look at that move f5 brilliant you
notice now the e4 square for the night
is gonna be devastating
Wow that what am also f5 just blocking
the check and reinforcing your kind of
what's the word I'm looking for is
you're a stranglehold on the e4 square
hmm even if that were to check the
Knight wants to get to a light Square
outpost because the dark square bishop
and why is that even not material for
his difficulties here great concept 94
now you window addition 26 rushing and
Eric paying the price here that you know
for his lack of development of that
opening strategy by Elena she's
radically switched switched up her her
concept from Orthodox play to these
unconventional Bishop g4 lines but
they've worked out but never count Eric
out he's going to fight until the last
drop of blood and that 26 is a
very powerful piece so what Lena is
trying to do is actually if she can play
d6 and just remove that defender of the
bishop because the bishop does look
really strong if you can imagine that be
pawn not being on the board then the
bishop will just stay there for the rest
of the game and Eric try swing that rook
taste of a queen bee boy check should
pick up the e4 pawn oh I thought rook c5
there was winning but now Queenie for
and for the time being blacks king is
safe Alina can can push her see pond
that is a greedy move Queen SIG's eight
so that is a greedy move in that win g6
look at Aaron just with no time on the
clock keeps 54 rook before room for the
g4 was nasty
yup now h5 is still an idea wait a
second how are you protect you 6 because
h5 h6 exactly okay you've got to put
Queen be free enough or maybe minivan up
lower okay that's also oh I was seeing
Queenie for just giving up the e6 bond
and trying to run Oh Queen h4 and nice
Queen six h6 just in the nick of time
gosh this game really had me nervous
there Kia f7 go get Queen C want to
kinking up sell it Erik reminded me of a
like a video game posture
chop off his legs he keeps fighting you
chop off his head he keeps on fighting
so just admirable by Eric but there's
too many pawns and he win ce6 I mean
just laying the c4 pawn or is he where's
that rook going Lina playing with some
fire hicieron or we need four check
she's defending the group with his check
and then because you know seven is rook
d1 me that's a really nice move rookie
yeah mm-hmm that rook is stuck I get
super any Queen Eaters rupee 7 - uh-huh
okay now that would be 7 finally freedom
and hit her a Jeff note I mean I was
acquitted for me
o Queen F for p2 queen or Queen D how do
you keys where this was slippery brook f
123 and then ricochets lion-o let the
King out of her clutches here this match
has been just really keeping me nervous
for mojo letters one game one incredible
battle after another were so many phases
in Eric with the results but I'm so
impressed - Lina after that loss I can't
get over the fact that she maintained
her composure she's won two in a row
these are critical winds bringing the
match back under control with 20 minutes
left in the three women and she goes
back to his line here with putting
pressure on the d5 pawn the c7 square I
think that Eric probably should change
up from this I'm not really enjoying the
position he has from the black site it
might just be perfect personal
preference excuse me and I just don't
feel comfortable when I have no space
for my pieces as he does here but he's
gone to it he thinks that it's a
reliable resource against this opening
Queen eight forged tickling the h6 pawn
comes to mind yeah good idea inducing b5
and that weakens the c5 square now we
saw the last time this happened Eric
eventually managed to whip up some play
on the Kings side here
aleena with the strong move Bishop e5
it's just a very pleasant position for
wait I agree
it certainly is in ninety six or Eric
going back to this little two nights
tango
90 of 696 we've seen this game after the
game and now Bishop f5 comes in with the
tempo so you got always it to be
unalloyed for that move as the c7 pawn
is an issue yeah
and it's just annoying that you can
never capture Ani whoa something about
this looks yeah we I think we both kind
of noticed the same thing at the same
time but maybe this holds together a
chicken does the last time Eric play the
c7 was not protected by a rope
importantly here there's no Bishop takes
e7 monkey business but I like what Alina
does to now e4 is weak the Queen on b3
pinning the f1 so there's no f5 and
interest I would like to take the bishop
and have two bishops against two nice
but opening the D file when your queen
can't really get out the way is not a
good idea so what about this takes e5
and Queen d7 well then I used to take on
I see what I five is there no you are a
sneaky sneaky guy thank you you see that
as a compliment it is a comment but I
actually think in that line if we look
at it in 95 de5 Queen d7 94 Queen at
five let's go east six you're trying to
give up my pawn on the worst square for
you no way you have to compromise your
pawn structure that's a good that's a
good move but as you pointed out I like
I also like the two bishops okay so he
goes for Bishop d6 can you in against me
yeah cuz 95 that's just gonna leave him
with that terrible pawn structure okay
so f4 is there some kind of Knight takes
e5 that no no way I think he messed it
cuz wait at four ninety five ninety and
rook T 400 or that no yours is better he
blundered at four I'm pretty sure maybe
I for Bishop before a ninety five but
then there's no G five maybe it doesn't
lose actually because after 95 you of
aged six we're saying is F for Bishop b4
and 94 96 85 the ponies that the knight
on e4 is under its attack so you'd like
to make Knight g5 is responding hey
you're nice stuck to protecting f7 then
you h6 is black you take my knight I
take yours bro can I just share a line
of you yes there's this line 95 96 yep
Queen Queen g5 and then I noticed this
idea probably all wrong rook chief for I
see what you're doing I too for Queen f7
I'm 28
I don't know just my conclusion and drag
the wrong piece and well the king is
safer black because you white lost the
Queen but why he's up upon the end of
this very long variation nice one Danya
you have a 93 I feel like that's I feel
like a lena missed a chance to really
just not black out here now Queen g5 and
black is in the game where Queen f6 rook
f4 or maybe 95 here okay 94 she choose I
can't figure out which movies right hey
Dyna though look at the time situation
alina up what 40 seconds she's really
just moving very quickly he is abortion
very impressive given eric's the more
experienced player but a time management
has been excellent and you can just
sense the last two wins the confidence
level rising but that was a big misstep
by Alina because now look at that Bishop
on p7 just slicing through White's
position really tying down those Knights
this is a very very dangerous situation
for Alina I actually want to play f4 and
f5 but I don't do you were able to
accomplish on time so she retreats her
Knight to c3 probably evidencing the
fact that maybe make d5 is better than
94 look g4 though just swing that rook
to the g7 folks 95 oh my goodness
that was quick Wow Oh quick turn around
and look at that just boom boom and g7
Falls and this is just indefensible for
black and what a turnaround for Lena she
lost those final games of the 5-minute
she was dead lost filthy might take C a
check that's just that is filthy stop
Ouija oh yeah and then you just take
back here that's an Eric Rosen type of
tactic and alina uncorked that one but
what doesn't say Danielle if she went
down three games and now she doesn't win
her third straight game and that's huge
she missed that win and lost that game
where she lied Eric to promote when Eric
was down a piece but since then she's
gone on the tear and she has proven the
dominant player in the three minute plus
one second increment time segment here
absolutely and just just incredible
composure and I keep mentioning it but I
it impresses me so much because I I
would not be capable of something like
that in all honesty so I mean it just
shows
the resilience the desire to win and
anna-lena has just been so impressive in
the three-minute portion in both of
these matches she's got to be a little
bit careful here we all know what Eric
is capable of so a few more precise
moves required but you know this is
there's a wide margin for error here
yeah she's just gonna try to win an f7
pawn efore 85 check the Oh down the
seventh rank exactly many many plants
here that's exactly what she does very
practical just crushing through black's
rook ta trade trucks I guess that's fine
as well and Eric down to ten seconds to
Elena's minutes and I see five hits the
e4 pawn and as you said you have to
watch out if you are aleena because b4
is another idea for Black is challenging
this knight on c3 may be some kind of
Knight d5 check is going to be possible
but your e for pawn is weakening down
goes f5 King up - okay whoa throw that
check yup and now rook T 594 King III
not the best conversion but we check oh
there's some ninety oh there was taking
on b2 I was five there's still some
intrigue left Eric being tricky but
ninety four this b3 so I get to protect
my font and the flavor okay well that's
a buzz saw
okay it just mowing down the pawns okay
but now the pawn is not actually hanging
I would play off six don't take guns
okay yep she sees it she sees it oh nice
little try there we can hit very last
chance by Eric I mean just look at this
there's no time on the clock so King a
for will screw of the a5 pawn Oh Eric's
going for it huh so King I feel her
problem is that King on b5 is blockading
everything that's a good move b3
nice try yes Brooke 96 yeah my goodness
oh no no but this h5 would be five again
oh but that was close that was really
close there Eric also almost lost some
time oh come on nervous
H how does she five and give up the rook
for the pot at the right moment but 93
don't miss Knight b3 oh yes he does not
Wow but now that night you know can he
chase down the spawns no that was not a
good move every temple is important King
before late night Knight to g5 QB 3 but
woody 3 drinking
363 no no not like this no not like this
Oh maybe still winning because can you
hold my goodness straightest h7 and you
win you push them all on my goodness g5
g 6
oh my guess we're gonna have to look at
that game there were many missed
opportunities there and Eric Rosen he
had just the dwindling seconds on his
clock he was not able to find it but
kudos to Eric because I try to pull on
Eric here every one of us would have
lost that game earlier and Eric's
somehow almost swindle a half-point as
we start the next game I'm pulling up
the analysis board we will look at that
in a little bit more detail because holy
smokes
Eric Rosen he just go back to waste that
pawn was rolling for black the beet pond
all the way down and Danya was looking
at 96 check and if the king came to a 4b
- it looks like the rook is cut off
actually it was cut off
wait you were totally right my goodness
he had it here he had it there no but
Rock age 595 yep exactly room I'm 95 and
the rook cannot get there and the pawn
is queening so Eric missed one
opportunity there just because - I'm
yeah you went King C for the rook came
back and then finally we were talking
about this line here what a Lina need to
do is keep the black King stuck on the
first rank for as long as possible from
bring the King in then the Kings came in
here
critical moment King f3 blunder Knight
f7 check picked up the H pawn and black
survives let's go back to the live
position because a lot has happened I
still plan on g5 but kudos to Eric Rosen
for somehow someway every single game
providing us just the utmost
entertainment watch out for 92 when
you're on exchange this is think this is
incredible one game after another just a
dogfight
I am so impressed with Eric's resilient
I mean we played a game at the US Junior
I think in 2011 and that is the first
time I got a taste of who Eric is I mean
I was up a full rope in that game and I
lost he found one incredible chance
after another but here he just he's lost
lost the thread of the but Knight of
five there yeah now I don't think he's
got enough for the exchange although
Elina has significantly weakened her
King sight so this is gonna unfold in a
very interesting fashion and I like the
decision to take on
for because what happens when you're up
in exchange if no files are open the
rooks are not that powerful and actually
if you look at this starting position
right now it does kind of have that
feeling that White's minor pieces are
doing very well because the chief or
pawn is under attack
I'm turning 19 f5 to remove the defense
of the d5 pawn so I would just take back
probably with the rook on c3 I want to
wing that rook over to the King side and
because only White has a dark square
bishop if you're making more like Knight
f6 Bishop e5 feels very powerful mm-hmm
good points I like what Elena's doing
here basically opening up the center
maybe if the rook is gonna come into
play on see it at some point but Eric
you know he's got to just Bank on his
King side play that Bishop d3 check
though tying tying that Bishop to the
pawn
I think Elena's without a doubt
objectively better but maybe there
should be five here as you pointed out
Robert just keep black a bit tied down
the d4 pawn will be protected then
knight on f6 is kind of pinned if you
will because it needs to say protecting
the Kim
if ninety five then maybe Bishop takes
c6 because h4 is hanging
are there any swindle 94 is a very good
move great move there by Elina and she
found it very quickly look at that I
mean just incredible Bishop e6 there's
Queen takes h4 shutting down any chances
of queen g4 check so should you just go
Knight f3 and gave up the rook I guess
the problem there is then I'll take your
rook and then try to play for Epps ace
at some moment yup rook takes c3 does
something similar may be queen d3 but
then after Queen h4 24 there's the move
f5 forcing a trade of Queens big issue
as Dinah's pointing out is if you give
up and this is what's happening 19 sep
2015 10 game is surprisingly not easy to
win and f5 is run by Queen a for Bishop
e6 would almost be checkmate if this
were a bish wanna fade instead of a row
but you're right that this endgame here
is not as easy as you would like the
bishops are so powerful definitely and
why it's got some pawns to how many
three ciggies got through six against
four so that is far from elementary
Queen g5 okay so Quincy won checkmate
being threatened is that a big threat
see one knots pretty small you don't
really have to deal with it an f5 also
pretty big threat winning the bishop
Queen g5
how does white deal with both of these
at the same time Bishop e2 feels like
the only oh yeah
then maybe rook c8 I mean it's still not
easy those bishops or monsters and what
I'm gonna do is why sufficient me to
pawn h4 like try to keep the pressure on
the black King because the king is
exposed over there with no G pop mm-hmm
I'm a alii true there might be
Queen f5 some kind of then f6 you're
stirring up your king because h4 right
away under that think about that
Quincy one enough five he wants queen
takes p7 what about f5 here about be g6
yeah that's the problem again those
incredibly resilient idea resources in
every position she just says I'm gonna
take this pawn prove it prove it Eric
and what's it gonna do now is gonna play
g3 he doesn't down minute and 20 seconds
every single game it's the way she's
turned on just the velocity is is
unbelievable g3 just go back to g5
remember White's not to exchanges now
he's he's only up upon for those
exchanges he still has his bishops but
just not quite getting as much counter
play as he s he needs here may be real
case again and trying for Luke c12 check
that's exactly what she does I like the
Queen on h6 to the Queen g5 because the
Queen were on age 60 with her in Queen
each one mate at the end of these works
t1 line hmm okay Brooke C 126 how do you
defend against that you can't Queen h6
my goodness and look at the speed once
again every single move has played fast
and confidently I would he said he's pre
moving King g3 here I would imagine
said almost but I was like Queen h4 try
to flag how about rook c7 no that would
be a narrative ski special and be too
much but Queen h1 check King g3 how do I
finish the game rubbed you on check King
f4 like this King is trying to win age
six check we all know how dangerous
Eric's King can be in the open the king
is just gonna run back to d3 and maybe
all the way the Queen side view
to a 600-page to plate very fast by Eric
I don't think I like upside on my guests
six that plugs the H file
maybe f5 she's gonna play for at five
okay f5 yeah at five takeoff time dude
and the bishops got a stand that
diagonal otherwise Queenie for check
exactly submission
oh now for four resigns whoa who died
too quickly
but it was enough because Aaron just
with one second impossible to defend
and it was lost anyway after Queenie for
neck smoke Wow so the Luna Carson Scott
takes the lead at this mm-hmm she has
time for ed you know there's five
minutes and forty seconds remaining on
the timer for the three minute portion
she would love to get another victory
and keep on pushing in the three-minute
portion but if I'm Eric and I get a
tough position I mean he's always
playing it out to the very end but
something about this gives me the notion
that he probably prefers to try to duke
it out in the bullet rather than in this
three-minute portion yeah I think Eric
Eric is confident in his in his bullet
skills once again he's very experienced
but you know they've got in this type of
position a couple of times in by the way
f5 yeah what was if I was just whoa ah
but maybe a B maybe a black hold on
there but still I don't like this
position I feel like Alena is very very
strong in these positions of the space
advantage additional pressure sorry that
moved eight yo or is just like asking to
be played yep but what about a be there
that's the problem I was think of night
seeks b5 I wasn't sure about a pea
sacrifice it's not it's a peace offering
if you will and C be a be something like
this I don't believe in it it looks too
I'm a ploy ski that was I I just let it
be known everybody might have missed
that pun but I didn't I'm always there
for you Robert I appreciate about five
f5 the night of fate but that doesn't
look still that pawn on e6 that's been a
theme throughout the match a weak pawn
on e6 although maybe you have takes c6
Knight a c6 yeah and why it's got to be
careful too it's easy to overextend
yourself in these situations by the way
go ahead Knight takes b5 here not
possible the rook on a a but Elena's
gotta make a mental
yourself the rook ever leaves a these
Knight takes d5 Knight takes d5 ideas
become possible
I was looking that way earlier watch out
494 because the Menem Eagle c3 is pinned
and this pawn h5 is under attack so
Knight of six dual-purpose move here and
I guess 94 is not actually a big threat
you swing my rook to see one to protect
him to it I gonna calm down recognize it
there is a pin but it's not so dangerous
and now this pawn h6 might be a goner
I'm worried about that because bishop of
fate just snagging upon h6 feels like
it's in blacks future yeah Elena decides
to go Queen d2 prophylactically I agree
though Bishop f8y it's not clear who's
who's on the initiative here both sides
are kind of testing the waters
but that pot on h6 I'm a little worried
about it and there we see it yeah rook
h1 not the type of you want to play it
but note that the open a file looks
wonderful for black but the only square
available is a 3-1 because the knight on
c3 covers a dude nice move Wow
please take me on age 6 I'm swinging my
second rook to the age file and I'm
trying to crash through down the line
there Wow
good move f5 is that e6 fun yeah that e6
pawn is an eyesore a knight g55 rook e1
go right after it what is black - maybe
Knight back to f6 yes as long as the
positions closed era can afford sit to
spend some Tempe and I was gonna say you
didn't make that you miss wreckage for
it's okay it's not the end of the world
the position is still closed as you said
you can afford to make moves that are
not of serious consequence because
there's no way for white to crash
through but at some moment you do have
to worry about a 95 or Knight g5 where
white is advancing in the position but
for now just play Knight of 6 but don't
spend 40 seconds the plain items next
yeah it's just got to make a make a
decision here I mean that h6 took out
the rook h1 I was briefly considering
night at 5 and Bishop she said oh that's
terrible in g4 comes in Erick's he's
taking too much time here and again we
see this huge time advantage for Oh Lina
that's that's allowing her to deliver
these critical moment
so what's he thinking about he's just
free is just freezing here I think cuz
that five that that can't be good right
there we see it should have been played
30 seconds faster mean it 18 seconds a
night of sex you just cannot afford to
spend that much time on a movie and it's
not that Erik's playing badly of course
that's not what we're suggesting no stay
he'll this 45-second zoom in his two
minutes and Brooke h1 played by Alina
just trying to secure the first rank and
two you know you could take me there I
even thought would take with a deep pawn
to give the same that the d4 square for
the night exactly because the night
would have loved to be on d4 but Bishop
e7 good move by Eric he can think about
playing his came to eat for instance but
for if i'm melina f/4g for f5 yeah and
that knight on c3 doing this very
important duty of guarding a2 and it's
it seems like like as his pressure along
the a file but it's it's hard to
practically take advantage of it so is
he going to induce f4 the one thing is
you can't move your rook away from the
hol just yet because then Bishop g5
comes with the tempo of winning bah-bah
mm-hmm and now I will be ready to take
it if you leave it here for this long so
f4 play there we go so take it rook a to
I think is good it has to be right
because that Queens gonna infiltrate to
a6 at that point you can even chuck your
pawn on on age six mm-hmm
don't like that move because if the if a
queen lands on h4 by the way Bishop f8 g
five Bishop takes age six I like the
look of Rob probably doesn't work the
White's got rugby one in the end
ah nice fine Bishop FA g5 Bishop h6 gh
Queen h4 it looks like you're going for
a meeting you tack he does something
similar with Bishop to c5 but again
that's not the end of the story though
black gets a ton of pawns for the piece
after rook be one Queen g4 indeed that's
a very nice move Bishop c5 g4 not the
move just we knew it instinctively but
you had a clear okay to go for the a
file and the c6 fun that's the critical
situation here and now Alina sticky do I
play I've looked to be one on itv1 and
says she was Queen e2 holy cow there's
no way we Queen g1 probably rook F 1
Wait Wait Varrick please what was
rupture one okay sewer that still wins I
mean 3g5 this is like a study night take
see - how are you gonna beat me win a
one and then okay bring the King to e8 I
would start by just dealing with these
long-term eight threats but where are
you gonna position the rook I feel like
that's another problem you're right the
rook is just out of good move next one
yeah holds on for now now Queen Chi to
Queenie for us possible there's just too
much 93
I like 93 there 19:30 stop the beat
ponens just did that's true yeah I think
you're right she's he's gonna bring the
king in and after that well what are you
gonna do if you're white yeah it's just
an easy position of playing time for
Eric if he needs can gain can gain some
time to just by playing King EA Kim D
southern Ally not holding on for the
time being but when the time is right he
can also spend that pawn forward and he
will he can he certainly will and this
looks like this collapses and that is
the last game to the match will be tied
yeah what I mean a missed opportunity
there for Lina we're gonna just go back
to that moment as much as we like to
crap jokes at each other's expense here
you know we go back before g4 was played
we rotate state when I understand my g4
was played to go and play g5 and protect
this pawn on h6
but that pawn is actually not nearly as
important as you would think
rook a to saying well you the rook has
nowhere to go you have to take my reckon
82 Queen a - and then go ahead try to
win my h6 pawn because I'm just going to
put Queen h6 and go right after your c6
pawn so if the bishop is still entombed
by all the white pawns there and what's
wise it is 26 we've got the Knight to a5
go right after this e6 pawn and because
on light square the dark square Bishop
cannot protect it but on that note
that's all these jokes when we have for
just a second Danya and I will take a
quick break the players are gonna
stretch their legs try to refresh
because ahead we have a tied matchup
heading to the bullet stay tuned
everybody we were back in a few
[Music]
well as Jesse James it's not about the
money money money but there is prize fun
at stake here in the IM non-gm speed
chess championship brought to you by
chess comm we see that in these
quarterfinals the winner gets $200 and
then there's two adults with I would
percentage but more importantly that
winner of this match advances to the
semi-finals has a chance for eternal
glory absolutely
and speaking of glory this match is tied
it's a dogfight and because this match
is tied a quick refresher on what
happens if it's tied at the end of the
bullet section we have a 4-game bullet
mini match one plus one additional four
games if there is a winner of that then
they win the match if the match is still
tied after those four additional games
there is a single Armageddon game white
is five minutes black us three minutes
but of course as an all Armageddon games
black gets the draw so black draws the
game then they win the match and I'm
worried what do you think are we getting
to a tiebreaker to that you know what I
don't think so just because I feel like
someone's gonna pull away here I just
feel like someone's gonna pull away I
have no idea who it is but as we saw in
Teddy against Danny I certainly wouldn't
mind another tie prick I mean those
tiebreaks are just edge-of-your-seat
entertainment and this bullets actually
gonna be edge-of-your-seat entertainment
as well yeah I think I'm gonna pull away
from you because I'm really just you
know I'm tired of you today
but nah done it's been great and I love
comes a bullet with you because you're
such a fantastic bullet player I'm not
nearly as good as you are in bullet you
come up with these little tricks and
have these ideas where I think that once
I will pre move in this direction and so
I'm going to come up with this idea just
to say if you pre move there I win a
pawn or I get an advantage in some way
so without further ado let's bring on
the bullet everybody right in the chat
who you're thinking is gonna win this
match and we have liftoff with B for by
Eric so none of this London system he's
gone before and I'm no no no we got to
restart the bullet come on no Petrov's
in the but what is I think Dini Pulido
has hacked Helena's account and we went
from the Petroff into a potential fried
liver if 95 into d3 we have an Italian
game how many different openings could
we have just seen in the FIR
five that was the transposition of
transposition yeah and finally I'm
telling with d5 aleena expanding in the
center this is a hard position to play
in bullet though c5 is a very topical
move but you've got to watch for h3
black doesn't normally want to give a
giveaway that Bishop right and here the
e5 pawn is the problematic piece oh wait
what
okay h3 played that you could take I c4
and yeah I'm sure then you could play f6
and the reason why giving up the bishop
is not so good for white is when I play
f6 well first I can play off six there's
no pin and the light squares don't feel
weak when I'm the only one with the
light square bishop so right now I think
aleena is off to a great start look at
all the time Oh
17 seconds Inc c5 though Eric had Knight
takes e5 there and does he still have it
he know that the divine 81 it's hard to
say or I wouldn't risk it just because
he has 29 seconds if it backfires you'd
know I died he's gotta move his a knight
back yes and I could be eighth wait 93
83 hangs upon man well maybe he can take
and go something like 94 and try to
establish a blockade but I mean he 33
extra salween is just savage here just I
love this rook to d8 go for that c5
buckin your c3 pawn will be too happy
about it but you can go for it yeah
neither earlier be for pot after that no
this is collapsing yeah Eric could play
g4 but now f5 is possible and she's
saying you have to put your knight and
survive and she's gonna take it I think
I would take it I would take it and
again we discussed the obstacle or
bishops that doesn't mean it's a draw
there are ropes on the board and all of
these gaping holes for white Bishop c4
as possible and bring the king and
slowly look at the time
how is she up so much timing crazy Oh c4
though a nice by just backfired
she played too quickly that happened
sometimes rook t6b 5 and now up some oh
man and now c7 is lost and all of a
sudden the tables turn Elina yeah just
way too fast there that stretch my
goodness now now he's got the connected
passers yep three at least you know
she's gonna put a hook on b3 and then
the D pawn is good I think that with
proper oh my goodness
what was that proper play isn't a thing
in bullets Ezra gay 5 now Plato forever
this is if
playing you to class again Daniel I'd
probably make you make a bunch of moves
and then you give the proper technique
and like okay split but they do I give
you throwing you showed that you can
defenses anything but okay but in bullet
I mean the thing is this increment is is
huge here obviously otherwise this would
be flag central and Boop
I think Elena's sensibly I mean I would
baby push like a five or something but
oh my goodness
was it a mouse tip or was that
intentional I think it was intentional
and I think Alina pre moves I have three
I mean still had bad they've transposed
again so many different openings
Budapest to the English they're going
through all the European nationalities
here didn't uh chess explained his
matching to Lina had this from the white
side if I'm not mistaken I feel like
this was the type of position he went
for maybe I'm thinking the wrong magic
and I recognize that structure you're
right and you should have going against
these C pawns in the long term so that's
what the problem is for black is it's
not like you know it's the end of the
world doubled pawns there aren't so bad
but a queen eight for Brooksie one pile
up pressure their take on c4 I dare you
happy an extra pawn but with it a triple
isolated pawn structure still the c4
pawn can be captured but it's not going
to happen
Elena speed is also incredible nappa
slip takes h3 coming she just has to
make the adjustment if she's winning in
an endgame just to consciously flow done
how do you defend against Bishop takes
h3 though that's a devastating for I was
glad to say that that's a bishop III
just Oh the b25 hanging I would still
maybe take on h3 I know it's temporal
eons oh he takes picture that's right
yeah CD do you have nice t5 is that what
you're getting at here thank you just
might because there's no discovery of
course but it's it's definitely very
flimsy maybe Bishop c5 here I was just
thinking that been 94 that's so annoying
that's exactly what Eric's butting heads
against Bishop before maybe and this
should be something very sensible okay
II four and if you take is he five gonna
be played or yep my guess is this has
got to be good for black but look at the
time again there's just no time to find
the accurate execution she's too quick
and too strong deadly combination
I'm looking at 94 check and just trying
to be sure that she wants course covered
I like it doesn't quite work though but
I mean this looks shaky bishop's III you
have a tempo never 51 ships III aha you
have to attack this rock and I put a
rook on d1 to protect this night there's
no other choice
I don't see another choice and she's
thinking so this is a for the right
moment to think maybe she should have
thought you know last move whatever but
at least she's stopping and pausing and
trying to figure out if she finds it
clutch clutch move here by alina rook up
to the game is definitely not over yet
Oh Bishop g3 check and they have four
pump I have 19 tonight have six
constantly in the picture 97 check 96
doesn't work as I've Knight takes off in
97 you're absolutely right that is we
just keep king g1 or KH 1
yeah I didn't know which Square to go to
5 seconds where he makes when every nice
things in east 6 light 93 93 you want a
piece you take on take a night ride
don't think oh I didn't like to go in da
first queen of 3 you have queen of 3
Queen f3 oh oh that's even nicer back
rank what a brilliant move there by
Alina Erik still fighting again that
boss they've chopped his legs off
they've nope he's still in the game but
just too much activity here for Lina and
of course the extra piece this is pretty
easy to win 94 checked and as long as
you know blender anything as you're
plenty on just look at this Bishop to c5
taking up squares don't give any
activity and just six ah oh wait bishop
no there's no bishop check oh wait wait
Airport yep six wins Oh native for rent
to g5 they're cutting it close but now
not if a knight h7 and just take
everything and now everything collapses
here waiting to be 65 you know just hook
go so I think I've pushed that pun and
okay Elena's 23 seconds and there's no
hope here for Erik get a Queen Queen
okay how could we be against Queen be
free free move what a very savvy move
there by Aerith maybe Elena would pre
move Queen b3 but she's on top of that
what a game Alina now at one point as
we're down under 18 half minutes off
with just over 18 minutes remaining
Alina one point plenty of time for Eric
Rosen it's just a one game match and
again just to remind everybody when if
you're in the middle of the game and the
clock hits zero for the overall match
they finish that
so it's not that you know if they're in
the middle game again matches not over
they finish that game even if Eric is
down one point or if Alina goes down one
point and there's say 12 seconds left as
long as they get a start that you know
for the match clock is over there's
still a chance like in football you know
you finish the play
exactly and Eric is playing these sort
of it looks kind of like those in some
ways those carrot con lines where it's
an interchange in d5 but there's a pond
d6 reven on d5 c5 by alina very
interesting very interesting move
opening up with g6 square for a night or
a bishop now it could backfire because
her Kingston but your King side is
beefed up by all of those pieces this is
about equal and now Knight c4 though I'm
not sure about c6 and I'm not sure about
Eric's play seems a little bit too
passive for bullet yeah then Knight f1
move going backward instead of just
attacking d6 some discovery 9h for I was
looking at night eh for trying to take
on it through a check as an intermezzo
but now Queen c2 is a good move and 97
so moving backwards bit of a
cat-and-mouse game they're kind of
testing the waters I would try to Bank
on getting my Knight to f5 purify where
Eric maybe this should take c6 maybe
aleena will take with a pond though and
then a threatened rook takes F stand if
you get the F file open and Knight comes
into f4 it seems like you're picking up
momentum f5g for an idea c4 comes is
right now are timely for Erick kicking
that night back but here comes that
night you need to go into e45 I push and
say hey what are you doing I'm the one
who has more space my rooks are on
better flies look at this is Brooke on
d1 the F rook is better here clearly
because now it's supporting Metro g4
just keep on pushing on that side the
board then of three moves to d2 because
she five squares under black school and
Anya I'm loving the way this is taking
form for Lina here well to borrow your
term Robert the bishop on issue just
entombed by those pawns very elegant way
that Elena's put her Knights on f5 and
f6 I wouldn't do anything rash or d5 is
tempting but it allows a nice e5 I would
just play sensibly in practically ninety
eight okay so she's reinforcing them I
don't have five still great position for
black easier to play she's swinging her
night around to e6 attacking that loose
pawn b6 covering covering this e5 square
maybe Elena's preparing d5 after all she
is 151 what is sad f3 is 93 check in the
video but maybe maybe why
have done that anyway now we're getting
is 95c once
rook c1 watch out for this I say hey
rook got six maybe five FS ha ha so 96
going after deformer turn I mean Black
has the better Bishop but with so many
trades happening he does I feel like why
should be able to get out of this but
look at the time 6 seconds he got his
move off but is d4 still just hanging
here um that's what Elena's thinking
chief Webber takes takes a knight c6 oh
my goodness what is going on here Queen
64 my gosh and rook to e8 rook to d1 is
just devastating 92 9th wonder as well
yeah but don't count Eric out because
he's about to steal to be six points
there's one thing we've noticed on this
match never count him out rook t1 though
five rookie five there 84 oh nice fine
because I was being a Jew even 93 who
know Jeter is so beautiful oh that was
gorgeous absolutely beautiful
no just boom boom boom was like one
second on each move that was
unbelievable tactical vision by Alina
Catherine we're gonna to ask her about
that what she's been doing to work on
her tactics because she found it all
pretty instantly and Eric you know now
these guys is off the position stem from
a Budapest he's going after the pawn
he's gonna take a five this CC pawns
diet you can correct me if I'm wrong but
I firmly believe that in bullet chess
having double isolated pawns when the
worst things possible yes exactly
because that's like driving a bus you
know you got a it's very hard to handle
it's not like white is worse per se but
in bullet you want to be able to make
decisions very fast and when you have a
weak pawns that already gives your
opponent an easy plan of attacking them
so she does of the two bishops she has
some Kings side play here I just can't
get it that was absolutely Savage and
and it just that would be beautiful even
in a classical game and here we have it
and that the pawn on c4 collapses so you
called it Robert this is looking very
bad though for Alina as somebody who's
played the gingy Indian from the black
side countless times I just love the
feeling of going after it clear target
where's whites like I have the two
bishops I know I should be doing well
but then you just keep an eye out
wait what about the zom-- pawns but this
is dope on say exactly
and here comes Knight d5 E and good
Maron Eric with with a very very strong
opening here after that debilitating
loss the Knights come to just plant
itself on e5 easy game for black Bishop
c6 can follow he can double in the
e-file that's what he does no target
squares for aleena it seems like she has
some plan the Kings side but it's gonna
be very hard to whip up any sort of
counter play for positions close to
close to collapsing not to mention she's
down upon and I love that Eric has
delayed c5 because it must be so
tempting to make that move but then the
d6 pawn does feel a little weak 96 just
put the 96 maybe there can be Bishop d7
yet to retreat but try to put the 96
okay here comes the Queen and 93 crusher
yeah 93 for King Oh Eric missing it
another chance and there it is
show me two ups want me to be fun at
five reinforcing the Queen very nice
move by bears for Queen h5 can I get
away with something like you gotta try
that in Bishop before Bishop takes h6
the problem is Eric is time management
looks better in this game Alina trying
something here along the GFL but
anything once here c5 is one try just
winning e4 I like that Bishop takes d6
well you're gonna be down to piece right
so Bishop e6 doesn't get you enough and
alright this is this should be
straightforward for him but he's going
to be on one point still and we're
getting into 12 minutes left in the
match yeah when do these games start
feeling like must wins this one I felt
like was a must-win but now that he's if
he converts this he'll only be down one
point does the next game become a
must-win or when do you all want done
after 10 minutes I think it starts being
a must I mean it's basically I must not
lose some games you can afford to draw
but gotta say this is a clutch clutch
performance by Eric here with with the
black beast is keeping his composure
would have best game but he played
aggressively enough and his time
management was better so definitely
clutch and just very briefly huge shout
out to over 8,000 people watching on
multiple platforms
you've got almost 8000 on switch alone
so thank you folks hope your seat belts
are tightly fastened these last ten
minutes Robert are going to be as
fascinating as this entire mattress bet
and it's been a roller coaster and if I
were going to be sure before but Jeff on
my iPod Falls
tactical shot the Delina needed h5
h5i III never takes you 3 I like that
idea of the high and low when I simplify
simplify
he has 6 seconds left yeah you never
kept rook t-55 bring that rook in yeah
we Nigerians a buzzkill and now before
he just pushes his bonding thing is the
king is safe but she's trying and he fix
here King aged six it just looks a
little scarier than it does and I see
five odds are too fast and there's too
many of them
rook d4 nice move winning the G formula
very clinical and Oh tricky but there's
King f6 check and you win the Brooke on
e5 Oh in a trying her best
Eric impression exactly ooh and yeah
this has been exciting stuff c5 by Luna
so he's taking a more aggressive
approach against the London stop this is
Bishop g4 stuff what she was doing in
previous games dude oh there it is
I spoke too soon here comes Bishop g4
and Eric is so good in the London so I
Alina has found her way in some homes
don't 25 wait if I was before no you
jinxed him I'm so sorry or bruising you
know all your faults VOC our friendship
I'm so sorry
era oh my goodness he walked her right
into it and Alina is so tactically alert
today yes she just had the I mean and
that's a very easy thing to miss an eric
resigns very wisely I should say you
know says now this is a must-win we've
entered must-win territory if he loses
one more game it becomes virtually
insurmountable Wow and talk about just
being on Form in the bullet Alina saw
that so quickly she gained you were
gonna have to say it I was busy jinxing
Eric Rosen
and then she plays it and it's like it
takes two I mean and let me just say
that's not always easy to see in a
bullet game I've missed that particular
tactic tens of times because you just
don't realize you know it's a quiet car
or oak on all the sudden there is a win
and Lina piling up on that c6 pun again
Bishop c4 this is already looking very
unpleasant for Eric once again how come
you say tens of times on dozens of the
times like it isn't usually dozens there
because I said it because I actually
wanted you to notice that okay that's
the only reason I said that cuz you're
about five rook c7 doesn't really help
so is black going to get F
it's one critical question uf6 now for
sure does maybe she should leave or not
only five I like that idea
this h5 is risky but if you're playing
for a win and then the e3 pawn got to do
it something you have to do I don't
really see how white responds it 9f2 I
may go back to five no actually owning a
perfect time to go back to exactly
especially now the black couples we can
even further this is not looking good
for although it's only upon as you said
Robert that move h5 it does weaken
blacks kingside permanently may be a
rookie one okey a but there's yeah there
should be four ideas that will hurt you
at some moment yeah Erika's played
quickly and well here this is probably
the best Bullock game he's put together
this far 91 is a good way several traps
is a six FII goodness or Bishop a5
rookie to fi is good oh my gosh rookie
you have a rookie you can't sacrifice in
a good way that's the problem if you
could somehow game ease position maybe
you look tasty three
I'm so sorry Erica keep jinxing you I'm
so sensible Robert I feel so bad now you
know the competence curses just no but
whatever we'll pretend it is just for
this match Eric Rosen I spoke too soon
every time they say Steph Curry's
free-throw percentage he misses the free
throw
you know how it is a now f5 just a bus
kill move look at that night on f8
completely dominated by the eponymous
five Eric doing what he can he's keeping
the bishop but now a threes got to take
oh oh it does go to show though a pawn
three scores from a knight dominates in
this pawn at five as you pointed out it
covers the vital scores Bishop d7 rookie
seven traps the Queen so H 56 h4 play
age not anymore but a trip we trust Oh a
blunder BC 7 but Elena's move is also
good enough it should be seven after
this I guess but then open up CC and
this is just 56 that's it
rookie 7 mm I don't know about that
Queen trade I know Lena with over half
of her time left I would slow down a
little you can take twice on c5 there
also and rook e8 probably rip c8 and
yeah I just said you take Tyson and
bleeding the clock here
not a bad idea c5 is hanging this is
just collapsing for Erik rook c7 so if
you're I mean Eric who's gonna have to
resign he probably should resign
you should resign right now right now
because I would say the importance of
having as every second counts now this
match is not over but only if he resigns
he can't afford to spend another minute
here okay seven and he should he's
hoping from Miss Piggy yes but she's
gonna see in a go King g3 and then 94
that bishops trapped still pay for I
wasn't going for his black so you be go
I wait a sec you know there was no rush
oh my gosh you might survive is 93 you
go off in the Jeep on the bring your oh
93 I guess he asked me to came first
rogue g7 though rubee 7 she wants to
next e6 it's gonna take on e4 no no
before it's so many pawns came out 14 g5
yeah too many people all of this game is
Eric Rosen might've say actually we have
seen some incredible tenacity there's
just too many pawns here King do
anything wins here hey 795 oh my skew
doesn't miss the fork and he barely got
that move off oh my gosh hey 7 she's fun
she's so much time left
I know 20 seconds just plenty of time to
think through these moves just check for
force Eric's got a resign she's really
good she's gonna big kingi oh my gosh if
King no way to me I know what he's
waiting for
wait 67 they're gonna go key but she
know I think she's prepared for that yes
then that was her preparation was
watching hair exactly bullet resourcing
this and now here is engine there's only
5 minutes and 25 seconds left I don't
know if he's enough time you need some
win these games and Windham just
immediately you can't wait he's just
gotta go for the throat here Lewis is a
brilliant bullet player she's and she's
made the adjustments I mean ever since
the three-minute portion it's like a
rocket that's taken off she's made all
these decisions so fast and she's had a
time advantage throughout and not only
does she has she's done without
sacrificing quality which is really
propelled towards at the top of this
match and she flat-out blundered that
pawn on e3 and Eric was in the driver's
seat and then he goes rook trapped and
after that yeah
you know maybe should've resigned
immediately and just an okay this game
is frustrating I'm over with it but
right now he's going all-in with rook on
the g5 the pitch 25 hoping to barrel
through get a check look at that nighty
plenty more you can't take 95 because of
Knight f6 and it's easy for you know for
me to sit here and my armchair say well
you should have resigned obviously we
take our hats off to Eric for incredible
resourcefulness in every position but
here this is just collapsing and we're
965 the wheels are coming off the train
is derailed the Rosen Express is not
looking not looking rosy right now yeah
it's a sad state of affairs for all the
Eric Rosen fans of which there are so
many and unfortunate for him Melina
Cashman sky has proven to be a very
sturdy competitor honestly I've been
extremely impressed with her play to him
Eric - Eric has he's not just being
resourceful he's come up with brilliant
ideas that night of five where he lost a
pawn before in that game and at 197 and
other games in earlier on when he was
playing those London system type lines
opening the H file it felt like he had a
good hold of things but just like I
leaned it against chess explain where it
seemed like things weren't exactly going
her way in the five minute in the three
minute and then in the bullet that's
where Alena feels like she's at her
strongest exactly maybe five oh and
she's not missing a single chance I mean
every time she has a little tactic she
sees it and she sees it fast look at the
speed of conversion here this is and and
shouts of chess explaining the chap by
the way I see you there Krishna
thank you for joining us I know you had
a fun match with Alena and how about
you're rooting for it right isn't that
what happens when you lose to somebody
you always brutal you can't beat them
join them
precisely thank you Kevin Durant and so
F for just go for something but Eric
don't say his name because you know what
happened he was on the words I will
never forgive him so that is the name
that cannot be mentioned just for your
knowledge Robert for future matches okay
makes anything but Kevin Durant any okay
cool just making sure that I have your
permission now and rookie five check the
problem is the can you go King g5 like
you would like to because I don't see
five pangs and now she's certainly
hanging Oh Eric trying his best thank
you and I say look at today every little
gem she's squeezing it out like
lemon that's squeezing and squeezing but
the problem is again the time is seeking
down two minutes this is mathematically
impossible even if he miraculously ends
up winning this game and look at that
tricky move King e6 rook c5 check was
the idea to pick up the a5 on so I would
just take that a pawn at some moment
soon because otherwise it over c5 now he
does and I would even milk the clock
here as much as possible but with four
points up that's just it yeah Wow
this is this is it this is it this is a
Lina captain sky winning the match shout
out to Eric Rosen because well he's a
worthy competitor he's proven that in
both of his matches thus far he's a
great streamer he does amazing
instructional videos absolutely and well
Alena captain sky ain't just hats off to
her because she has really been a very
pleasant addition to the i-i'm
speechless championship and she's very
close to her GM title she's like 24 and
90 something shown her capable herself
capable of beating the best so as you
say her you know we love to roast roast
these IMS that's part of our job
description but the end of the day I
mean both of these players are such such
great competitors and such great people
honestly that that it's very hard to
it's impossible to you know to pick
sides both both deserves the highest the
highest phrase for the fight that they
have put in and for the for the very
positive impact that both of these both
of these players make in the chess
community and I wonder now because I
feel like Alena catch this guy's a name
that might have been under the radar Oh
each pawn
wrong color the bishop so play Bishop
III th G nice move and now X this is
should be lost yeah just king g4 yep
pushed that pawn and now son alena wins
but I was going to say dunya is I feel
like aleena is a name that was probably
not really thought of as a potential
winner of this event and she's proven
herself not just be a dark horse but
just to be an absolute monster
because Christophe is a tough first
round pairing for her she need that one
out now she's o+ for again
Eric the match is closer than I would
say the score indicates but she is poor
and maybe even plus five she wins this
game so just props to Alena cash and
Scott and most impressive perhaps you
know her speed in the bullet section I
just you know when you don't play a lot
of bullet throughout your life it's it's
hard to just turn up the speed like that
but she's managed to do just that I
wonder what kind of training she's done
before the match which is something we
might want to ask her during the
interview phase but props props Julianne
I mean just no words she's in she
definitely has proven herself capable of
winning this whole thing and being a
force to be reckoned with yeah and look
at these bishops for her right now I
mean the knight nc7 not a good piece the
bishop on CA trying to figure out where
it belongs and on the other hand white
is just staring down at the black king
side either by trading the dark squared
bishop may be throwing Knight e to g5
going after the other diagonal in the e6
square and she just castles just a very
practical decision take on g7 first
maybe or yep knee up
Bishop e4 and this is officially the
last game of the match so Eric of course
trying to score the consolation goal we
know that some of the prize money is
tied up in the actual score so he
definitely has incentive to finish
strong and uh as you said Robert this is
definitely closer than the match scored
reveals he's been in another epic match
and shout out to be JH for the donation
calling this a sick match we really
appreciate the donations go to the
players so for anybody who is in the
giving mood well the players receive any
donations that you make so shout out to
UB JH and thank you to everybody who's
been tuning in following and as I said
earlier you know not only is this match
not over we have this final game but we
have the interviews after the match and
then we'll be back in something like
four hours yeah because we have Gotham
chess leve rosin taking on Teddy Coleman
and this evening so it's going to be a
very fun day we're only just getting
started were head and in this one
unfortunately fair Rosen this is the
final game and he's also down thirty
seconds almost yaha again the time
management just incredible and we will
indeed be back so going nowhere once
again we've got over 8,000 people on
which we hope everybody's staying safe
and we hope that chess is a bit of a
tool to keep to keep on sanity in this
time so thanks thanks again to everybody
don't go anywhere we got so much
intrigue ahead we've got a lot of
interesting questions to ask both of
these competitors
during the interview phase Robert III oh
just piling up five to follow my
goodness this is winning two Andolini
finishing on another win she finished
with a flex and props to Alena Cashman
skya Danya you and I are gonna take a
quick break we just gave the text set a
for an interview with both players
everybody stay tuned you will hear for
the players thoughts on a very exciting
match that came down to the bullet and
was decided by Elena's mouth speed and
her tactical vision we'll be right back
[Music]
and we welcome both competitors here
after what was a very exciting match
Eric Rosen our apologies that the match
did not go your way aleena
congratulations and lean let's start
with you what did you do to prepare for
this match how many tactics did you do
because you seemed laser-sharp when it
came to finding various tactics
throughout the match well I just wanted
to say that I was blundering a lot in
this match but I don't know different
Metis no I actually didn't saw so much
of tactics I'm just having my usual
training nowadays I of course tracked
Eric's games and I also even got some
messages from the people I don't know
who are telling me that Eric is very
tricky player and I should be careful
because he is definitely playing not in
my style so I should be really careful
and I was actually surprised that I
thought that my Transit's would be in
five minutes games but it turned out
that in this time control I was just
being outplayed totally and then somehow
I saw that in one minutes games it would
be vice versa that I would have no
chances and somehow I was just lucky
there Eric on your end you know when you
went into this match what was your
thought process liked it was there an
area a time patrol that you thought that
you would be able to pile up some points
I mean did you expect to go if that's
who game lead in the five-minute portion
for example yeah I actually thought I
would be I'd be more of a favorite in
the bullets but I don't know I guess I
like the positions so much from these
five-minute games I just wanted to think
for me to hit the to long and then and
it was just hard to adjust 2 to 3 minute
and then of the bullet portion so I know
it was a problem for me in the previous
match to just time management
unfortunately was not not able to adjust
quickly enough well Elena once again
congratulations to you a question about
your previous match did you take any
sort of
lessons away from your previous match
against Christophe any adjustments that
you consciously made on the basis of the
match that that you applied successfully
to this match well after the match my
husband told me that finally you should
work on this ready opening and
everything so you had a great lesson
finally to work on openings but when I
checked Eric's games I prepared against
him but mostly on openings was my work
done and here I just knew that with Eric
it will be more difficult in a way that
there will be fight till the end
I saw Eric's game against Elizabeth and
I saw that there was fight till the last
move so so I was ready that absolutely
in Eric there was one game where you
were down a queen but you had a night
left and you were going from A to C
seven be honest with us were you trying
to set up a queen sixty seventy eight
and get a stalemate again yeah of course
I mean she wasn't falling it for it
though I think I revealed too many
secrets from the previous match but yeah
that was the only hope she wasn't even
like taking the Knights from your games
those from mine we were impressed with
her with your resilience throughout Eric
so I mean you had a couple of games
where when we assumed the game is over
there was one where you didn't quite
pull it out in the end but I think you
were down in exchange and you somehow
got it down in a position where you had
a knight against two pawns so definitely
kudos to you for uh for reinforcing how
resourceful player your thanks yeah
driving my best but she she did a very
good job of converting blooming
positions so it was hard to fight mm-hmm
yeah we were both very impressed and we
thank you so much again for playing this
match everyone was on the edge of their
seats we had so many viewers really both
yuan and Alina do you have any thoughts
in your next round opponent isn't quite
up yet next scene I can't speak I'm just
tired from this long match your next
opponent is not determined yet do you
have a preference with whom you play or
it doesn't matter you're gonna prepare
the same way regardless I don't
even know what is the choice will be for
the next round so after the the Matt
will finish I will check whom I will be
playing okay well I like it taking it
match by match but again Eric are you
know our apologies imagine go your way
and Alena congratulations on another
fantastic win you move on to the
semi-finals of the IM non-gm speech
Chess Championship thank you thank you
guys
awesome match much alright and as we see
in the bracket now after that match all
is said and done Alena Castle sky moves
on into the semi-finals of this
tournament here in Danya and another
impressive performance by her she awaits
the winner of the match between leve
Rosman and Teddy Coldwell so if only we
only this match took place tonight and
we would be commentating it that would
be pretty nice wait a minute we are and
that match starts in riot around four
hours from now so I am just every one of
these these mattress has its own dynamic
has its own narrative and every single
one has kept us on the edge of our seats
so I'm very excited to see the evening
match and of course tomorrow John
against Lawrence Carissa against Gregg
these are just high profile matches and
this I am not a GM speech Chess
Championship has this you know as shown
one display of incredible fighting chest
after another it has indeed well Danya
you and i have had a fun day we will
continue the action later tonight as you
said in about four hours from now so for
all these all of you tune in
thank you so much for your generous
support of chess comm and the i'm nadjia
me chess championship for those of you
watching on chess TV twitch YouTube etc
keep on watching keep enjoying the chest
these Iams are producing a better show
than you could possibly ask for so we're
gonna enjoy more chests later today but
for now we're going to sign off
everybody stay tuned enjoy more chests I
don't know where the rate is going but
until then have a great Wednesday
afternoon if you're here in New York or
if you're in Europe have a lovely night
[Music]